hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about the top projects to be
learned in the year 2022 but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
so if you're a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session
first we will be covering the c plus
projects for 2022 followed by that we
will learn the python projects for 2022
and finally we will wind up the session
by learning the most popular javascript
projects for 2022. i hope i made myself
clear with the agenda now without
further ado let's get started with
today's projects now o to our experts
in this video tutorial we will be
learning about some c
projects for 2022 that would be helpful
for you to learn and grasp c
programming language in a practical way
we will not only discuss these projects
but also will make these projects from
scratch using some basic concepts of c
plus
so we will start with the hotel
management project in which we will have
the information of the items or rooms
that we have
what food items are ordered by the
customer and how many rooms are allotted
to them etc
then we will make another project on
registration and login form
in this project we will learn how to
make the complete structure and
functionality of the login and
registration form
first we will learn how to create a
login page in c plus in the menu there
will be different options like
registration login and forward password
etc
after that we will make a supermarket
billing project in c plus
in this project there will be various
functions that we will be creating for
this project like add function to add
the goods and products in the market and
delete to delete some products etc
and at last we will make an airline
registration system in c plus plus
this project on airline reservation
system will allow a user to book a
flight to a particular country of his
choice and he or she will receive the
ticket by filling in all the important
details etc
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and press the
bell icon to never miss an update
now let's go ahead
this project will be a hotel management
project in which we will have the
information of the items or rooms that
we have in the hotel and what are the
food items ordered by the customer
also we have the information that how
many rooms are allotted to them
also this project will tell us about the
sales and the remaining food stocks we
have and the total collection of the day
we will make this project in three parts
firstly we will discuss the first part
in which we will declare some variables
and then initialize them
after that we will enter the quantities
of items that we have in the hotel
then we'll make a list of items or menu
of items and rooms that we have in the
hotel
so let's start
now we'll switch to our code editor that
is dev c plus plus
so this is a code editor so here first
of all let's make a new file
we'll click on file and now we'll create
a new file
so now let's start with the project so
first of all inside the main function we
have to declare some variables but
before that
we will
write the header files that is hash
include iostream
and then the namespace standard
all right so we have included the header
files now we'll start with the main
function
inside the main function
we will declare the variable
so first variable that will declare
would be quant which stands for quantity
and the second variable would be choice
now we will declare those variables
that store the quantity of food items or
rooms
so let's say
the variable which will store the
quantity of rooms would be q rooms
and
we have to initialize it also
all right so similarly we have to do it
with the food items as well so let us
suppose one of our food item is pasta so
we'll write
q pasta that is quantity pasta
we'll initialize it with zero
similarly we'll do with the rest of the
food items
that is burger
noodles
and shake
and chicken
here chicken would be let's say chicken
roll
so these are our food items so these
variables will hold the quantity of
these food items
so now we will declare those variables
which will hold the value of the number
of food items that have been sold
so for example q pasta holds the value
of number of pastas we had in our hotel
and s pasta will hold the value of
number of pastas that have been sold
so let's start
similarly we'll write s
rooms that is sold rooms
we have to initialize it with 0 as well
and s pasta
similarly asmr
s noodles
as chicken
all right
now we will create some more variables
that will store the price of the total
price of each of these food items or
rooms so let's do that let's say in
total
underscore rooms this is the variable
name
it will store the total price of the
rooms
we'll initialize it with zero similarly
total
pasta
equals zero
total
burger
all right
so these variables holds the quantity of
food we have
these variables holds the quantity of
food we sold and these variables will
hold the price the total price of each
of the food items or rooms
so let's
comment it this holds quantity
so that it's easy for you guys
all right so here we have declared these
variables
now
now we will make a list kind of a
structure in which we will ask
the user to enter the number or
quantities of food items or rooms that
we have in the hotel
so
all right now let's do this
first of all we have to display a
message
but before that we'll use slash n and
slash d
so slash n means the next line and slash
t will add a horizontal space in the
output
so we need
that horizontal space
so we'll write
quantity of food
let's say items only quantity of items
we have
we have in a hotel
all right
now
we'll write rooms available
so we'll add slash n and
rooms
available
all right so after this
we will write c in and take the input of
quantity of rooms we have because here
we are asking to enter the number of
rooms we have
so we'll write c in
q rooms because it holds the quantity of
rooms we have
we have initialized it with zero
similarly we'll do it for the rest like
quantity of pasta like this will do
inside the
slash n
now we'll write the quantity of pasta
see in
q pasta
all right
now similarly
let's copy paste
and save some time
so this first was the pasta then
burger
and q burger
then there was noodles
few noodles
similarly we'll do it for shake
and then
here chicken is the chicken roll
so quantity of chicken rule
cue
chicken all right
so
one by one q room the quantity of rooms
we have to add q pasta the quantity of
pasta we have to add then quantum burger
we have
all right now we have to create a menu
to select the pasta burger room all the
items we have to create a menu like that
and for that let's do this
we'll write c out again we'll use slash
n
slash and then
again slash t slash
t
because you want some horizontal space
in that
we'll display a message saying that
please select from the given menu
options
all right
so it's a message for the users
or the customers i would say
now again we'll use slash n
because i want to add some new lines
so i'll use two selection
now
first is rooms
secondly we'll use only one selection
and
here we are creating the
menu to select the food items or rooms
so now we will write
pasta
and similarly we'll copy paste
so pasta then there was burger
then noodles
and there was shake
then there was chicken
chicken roll
we also have to change the numbering
that this is one this is two
then this is three
we are doing the numbering because the
customer will press the number
and then he can order
five
six
and now again we'll
in seventh position we'll add the
details or information regarding the
collection and sales
so
[Music]
we'll write
press seven if you want to see the
information
regarding
sales
and collection
this option would be used by the owner
of the hotel to check the total
collection for the day
all right now again
the eighth number
is for
if we want to exit
yeah
so this is done now
after that we'll display a message
saying that
please enter your choice
so we'll use slash and slashing and
right
please enter
your choice
now we'll write c in choice we have
already declared this variable
now based on this choice your order is
selected like if you press
2 then this pasta would be selected like
let's say if you want to order noodles
then you have to select four and if you
want to
order chicken roll then you have to
select six and if you want to
check the total sales and connect
collection of today
that is
for a particular day then you have to
click 7 and 8 for the exit
so a first part is done now in the
second part we have to add the
functionality to the choice part that is
if a user enters the first number that
is number one then rooms is selected and
then he or she have to add the numbers
of rooms they want
similarly for the other food items as
well
like if they want to take two burgers or
three burgers instead of one and we only
have one burger left
then also we have to display a message
saying that only so and so burgers are
left
so now let's start with it
so now we will write switch case
statements so when the user will select
a particular number
so that particular case would be
executed
so now let's
do that
right switch
and
inside the switch statement
we'll write choice
now the choice can be one two three four
five six seven eight
all right so now we have to create eight
cases for that
so case one would be
we'll start with it
there's a space between case and one
all right so case one would be
first of all inside the case one
that is the case when rooms have to be
selected so first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter the number of
rooms you want
so let's do that
use slash n
now
enter the
number of rooms you want
all right
now after that
the user will enter the number of rooms
that is the quantity of rooms
so now we'll take the quantity
in the quantity variable that is quant
variable
so the user will enter the number of
rooms that is the quantity of rooms he
or she wants
now we'll use a if statement an if
statement inside this if statement now
inside this if statement will check do
we actually have that many rooms in our
hotel or do we actually have that many
pastas or burgers in our hotel
right now so for that we have to write
down a condition
that is
q rooms
minus s rooms
is greater than
equal to
quant
that is
q rooms is the quantity of rooms that we
have and s rooms the number of rooms
that we have sold
so if
we minus both of these that is if we
subtract the quantity of room we have
minus the rooms we have sold we will get
the remaining rooms now if the remaining
rooms it's greater than equal to the
quantity of rooms that have been ordered
by the customer then
we can give the room to them otherwise
we have to display a message saying that
we don't have that many rooms or
something like that
so let's do that so we'll write s rooms
that is the rooms that we have sold
so initially its value is zero so we
have to add the values of quantity that
have been
entered by the user so we'll add the
quant variable that is if the user have
entered two rooms he or she wants then
we'll
add the add those two values to this
sold rooms
all right after adding the quantity to
the sold rooms
now
we will do the total price of the room
or rooms and for that we have the
variable
total
room
so we'll add this quant
into the price of a one room
to this total room
so
we are simply adding
total room plus
quant
into the price of a single room that is
let's say 1200 is the price of a single
room
if a person orders two rooms then it
would be like quant that is two two into
1200 2400 will be added to this total
room this total room is the total price
of a room
all right
now we also have to display a message
saying that these many rooms have been
allotted to you so for that let's
display a message first of all we'll use
slash n
like two times now we'll add some
horizontal space as well
all right
now we'll display this quant variable
and
write a message
that these many rooms
have been
allotted
to you
let me let's make it room or rooms
room or rooms have been allotted to you
so this message will be displayed
all right
now
this is the if block
now we'll have to make the else block
that
if the
amount or quantity of room entered by
the user is more than the remaining
rooms then we'll display a message
saying that only so and so rooms are
left in the hotel
so we'll use slash n then again slash d
now
write
only
q rooms
minus s rooms that is here q room minus
s room is the remaining rooms are the
remaining rooms so
subtracting both of these
variables will give us the remaining
rooms so
these were the remaining rooms
remaining
in
hotel
all
right let's not add these as there's a
single statement
also we have to use break
so we'll use break statement now
similarly we have to create case 2. this
case was for the room
so whenever a user click on this one
then this case will be
executed so similarly we will create a
case 2
so let's
we'll copy it now we'll paste it
so
[Music]
i will case to
so in this case
enters the number of rooms you want we
can't we can't write that
so we'll write past the quantity
so let's do that
we'll write
enter
pass the
quantity
all right so in this case
the c in would be same that is quantity
variable we have
so
now in this case the different thing
would be the q rooms instead of q rooms
we'll use the
q pasta that is the quantity of pasta
minus sold pastas
it must be greater than quantity of
pasta we have
then only if block will execute
otherwise similarly as that of this
block
will display a message
so now the s rooms instead of s rooms
here we'll use s pasta
which is initially zero
so we'll add the quantity of pasta to
this variable that is will add the
quantity of pasta that is ordered by the
customer to this variable
now
total pasta that is a total price of the
pasta
so the number of pastas ordered by the
customer into the price of a single
pasta let's say the price of a single
pasta is around 250.
so
quantity into 250
now
rooms instead of rooms let's do here
pasta is the order
so quant
so quant will display the
quantity
so it will display like if you have
order two past us will it will display
two
pasta
is the
order
and
q rooms here we have to display the
remaining so we'll do the q pasta minus
s
pasta and here we'll do is pasta
remaining in hotel or stock
pasta remaining in hotel
so it will display the remaining pasta
remained in the hotel now
so
else everything is fine now similarly
we'll do for the next
we'll copy it it will save some time
and paste it now this is case three the
case three is of burger so we will
write
burger
quantity of burger minus
salt burgers
similarly asperger
now the total price of burger
so let's say the price of a burgle is
around 120
and so
the remaining burgers q burger miners
asperger
the fourth case now
that is the noodles case
so enter noodles quantity
now case five
now case 5 is of shakes
so we'll write enter shakes quantity
now
case 6 we have to create
in the case 6 there is chicken roll
so let's do that
chicken
minus s chicken
also we have to change the price of each
meal like chicken roll
would be of around 150.
and this shake would be
120
noodles
140 let's say
burger is okay then
pasta is also okay
so we have created six cases as of now
so our second part of the program is
done now we'll start with the third part
of the program
so the third part will contain the case
7 case 8 and the default case
that is if the user enters any other
number which is not in the list that
will come under default case
in case 7 we have to display the
information of sales and collection that
is how many
money we have collected for the day and
the remaining food items etc
so
now let's start with the case seven
so when the user will enter 7 that is
case 7
then he want to see the details of the
information of sales and collection
so we'll display a message saying that
details
of sales
and
collection
all right
so after this message let's add slash in
slash t slash t
all right
so after this message
we have to display the number of rooms
we had the number of rooms we gave for
rent
and then the remaining rooms that is
minus the quantity of rooms minus the
soul rooms then the total rooms
collection for the day
so similarly we'll do for all the meals
like pasta burger noodles etc so let's
do it
so we'll start
display
first of all we'll add slashing
now
number of rooms
we had
display queue rooms that is the
quantitative rooms we had
now
similarly
number of
rooms we give
for rent
all right
so we'll write
s
runes
now we have to display a message
similarly we'll write slash and slashing
remaining
rooms
so
for that we have to simply subtract
queue rooms with s rooms that will give
us the remaining rooms
after that
the total price
that the room has collected or number of
rooms have collected
so we'll write
total
rooms
collection
for the day
now
it is stored at total rooms
this variable is storing the total
drives of rooms
this is the complete information of
rooms similarly we have to do it for the
burger noodle pasta etc
so we can copy we'll copy this part
and we'll do
copy and paste
and paste
again will paste
now number of rooms we had instead of
this
we'll simply write number of pastas we
had
number of pastas
we have to change that
number of pastas we
sold
yeah that would be right
now remaining past us
there are few minor changes that we have
to do
total
pasta collection
also make sure to change the variables
total
pasta
then
pasta
all right now
after pasta it was burger
burgers we have
number of burgers we sold
all right so
it would be q burger
and that's burger
remaining burgers
total burger collection for the day
all right
now we'll do same for
noodles
all right now shakes
number of shakes we had
number of shakes we give
we sold
remaining shakes
now there is chicken roll
number of chicken rule we had
all right now the case 8 the case 8 we
have used for this was the case 7 and
the case 8 we have used for exit as you
can see here
this is the exit case
and for that
we'll simply use
the exit statement the exit statement is
used to terminate the program to shift
the control out of the program or exit
the program
so here we'll use that so case it would
be
exit and inside that will use 0 0 will
mean that 0 millisecond
and now after that will have to use the
default case
that if the user enters any other number
that is not present in the menu list
then this default case will be executed
so in this
default case we'll display a message
saying that please select from the
numbers that are mentioned above so will
you slash n
please
select
the numbers
mentioned above
so this message will be printed
and also one more thing is there
we have to use a go to statement
and we'll have to label
a part with
m now i'll explain to you that why have
we used this jump statement that is go
to statement
so after making a choice we again want
to choose another option that is if i
have ordered two pastas then i also want
to order two
burgers as well
so
we will mark
or label
menu with m
so this is a menu please select from the
menu options so here we will label m
and
in the last we have used the go to
statements
so the go to statement here will
transfer the control to the menu after
making a choice
so again m is the label we have used for
the menu and we will use a go to
statement to transfer the control to the
menu after making the choice so that we
can make more choices
go to is a jump statement basically that
is used to jump from one part to another
part having a specified label
so we have labeled menu with m and this
go to jump statement will help us in
jumping to the menu after every choice
all right so our code is done we have
done all the things that we need
now we need to run it
and for that firstly we need to save it
all right so let's go to files and save
it
and now let's
select the destination folder
let's name it as
management
management dot cpp
all right
so the program is saved
now let's try to
compile and run this program
so there are some errors i can see
okay so
we have used
the semicolon
now
this will take care of many errors now
let's try to again compile and run
let's check q noodles
all right i think
cue noodles
so we have two backspaces now
let's try to compile and run again
hope it works now
so quantity of items we have as we can
see
so rooms available let's say we have 10
rooms
and quantity of pasta
we have
25 pastas in our hotel
and around 50 burgers
and 30
noodles and
30 shakes
chicken roll we have 40.
so this is the menu please select from
the menu options as you can see
first rooms then pasta burger noodles
shake chicken roll information regarding
sales and collection and then it to exit
so first of all
let's say
i want to order two rooms so i'll click
one
please enter your choice i have clicked
one and i'll press enter now enter the
number of rooms you want and let us
suppose i want two rooms
so as you can see
two room or rooms have been allotted to
you
now again the menu is displayed on the
screen now let's say i want
burgers so i'll click on three
and i want two burgers
and two burger is the order it is
displayed
now again i want a
pasta let's say
i want
six pastas
and six pasta the order i want
to order now shakes
let's have something to drink i want to
order
nine shakes
nine shakes is the order
and
let's say
so as we know that we have only 10 rooms
now let's try to enter 11
so first of all we'll enter one that is
rooms
now let's try to order
11 rooms
as you can see only eight
eight rooms available or remaining in
hotel so we forgot to add some space
over this part
but we can easily read it now as of now
so it is displaying the message that
only eight rooms are available because
already we have ordered
two
early it was ten then now only eight
rooms are available so this is showing
that if we
order
more than the quantity then it will
display this message
now let's say i want to
check the information regarding sales
and collection of today's
rooms and as well as meals so i'll
simply click on seven
now as we can see it will simply display
all the
sales and collection
rooms and meals as you can see number of
rooms we had 10 number of
rooms we gave for rent two remaining
rooms are eight
so total rooms collection for the raise
2400 as one room is of 1200
so similarly number of pastas we had 25
number of pastas we sold six remaining
pastas we had 19 so the total pasta
collection is 1500 so and so the burger
and then noodles and then shakes and
chicken roll
so this is the total chicken roll
collection for the day
that that is we haven't ordered a single
chicken roll also we can do one more
thing we can simply
display the total result of all the
collections of rooms and meals
so let's do that
now so to display the total collection
of the day all we need to do is to add
all the totals of pastas burgers and
rooms
so for that we have to go to k7
now we'll write slash and slash in
slashing three times
so here we'll write total collection for
the day
and after that
total rooms
plus
total
total burgers
total pasta
plus total
burger
total
chicken
all right after this we will use the
break statement
now let's run the program
so here it is rooms available
let's write 10
quantity of pasta 30
quantity burger 50
quantity of noodles 30
shakes 30
chicken roll
40.
so first of all i'll book two rooms
click on one and now two rooms
and again
if i'll click on
rooms
and then if i try to click
10 rooms because already we have two
sold we sold two rooms then it will
display that only eight rooms remaining
in hotel
now i'll
click on two to order pasta let's say i
have ordered five pastas
and
five pasta is the order
now let's say if we click on nine
although we know that only one to eight
numbers are available but if we click on
nine
so it will display a message please
select the numbers mentioned above
all right now let's say i have i want
ordered chicken roll
10 chicken rolls i want
so 10 chicken roll is the order now i
want to check information regarding
sales and connection for the day so
click on seven
and then here i can see
number of rooms we had number of rooms
we gave for rent remaining rooms and
total collection for the day similarly
for the pasta
similarly for the burger similarly for
noodles
shakes and
chicken roll as well
and this is the total collection for the
day 5150 exit
and if we click on it we can exit
so as we can see
this is our hotel management project
and this is how it's done
the code is bit long but it's worth it
you can also try this project on your
own
this project will be a login and
registration system in c plus
in which a user can register
log in and also if he or she forgets the
password then also it can be recovered
we will make this project using the
fundamentals of c plus like switch case
statements and file handling operations
etc
so let's go ahead and understand this c
plus plus project of login and
registration system
in this project first of all we will
make a menu page
in which there are options like login
registration
forgot password and exit
then we'll ask the user to select anyone
among those options
once the user has selected a particular
option
then we have to continue with the
functionality of that
so now let's switch to our code editor
and do its practical implementation
so this is our dev c plus plus code
editor now let's create a new file
now first of all we will include the
header files
the hash include iostream
then there is
f stream class or file handling
operation
hash include f stream
then there is string dot h
for string
then we will include the namespace
standard
now we will do the forward declaration
for three functions
that is login function registration
function and forward function
and after that inside the main function
we will make the menu for the login page
so let's start
first of all we are doing the forward
declaration
this is the login function
this is the registration function
and this is the forward function
now inside the int main
first of all we will make a variable
c which stands for choice c for choice
so now
we will make the menu page
so let's create
we'll use
slash t writing the horizontal space
now in the end we will use slash n
all right similarly we'll do here
welcome to
the login page
now again we'll do the same
slash d
slash t slash t
and now
underscores
menu
slash insulation
all right now we will make the options
so we'll do the slash t
now after slash t we'll add
vertical bar
then
we'll write press
one
to login
let's make it capital
press one to login
and after making some space then
vertical
bracket again
then end l
similarly
we'll copy it and do for option 2.
press 2
to register
all right
let's maintain the symmetry
press three
if you forgot your password all right
press 4 to exit
all right
so this is done now after that we will
ask the user to enter your choice
and for that we'll display a message
saying that
please enter your choice
but before that we'll use slash n and
some slash d's
all right now we'll ask the user please
enter your
choice
all right
now we'll take the input of the choice
that is c that we have already declared
next line
now
we'll use switch case statements
for example if the user selects 2 to
register first of all
then
inside the switch case statement in case
2 we will call the registration function
and if the user enters one then we will
call
the login function
so let's do that
let's create a switch statement
and see that is choice
now inside the switch statement first of
all we'll create a case one
inside this case there would be
login
we are calling this logging function
and then there is break statement
all right similarly now we will
create case 2.
so case 2 would be registration
here we are calling the registration
function
and then there is break statement
in case three there is forgot function
that is if the user forgets the password
then this function will be implemented
now
there is a default case
no now there is a case for
in case 4 there would be
a message saying that
thank you
because case 4 would be exit
so we'll display a message saying that
now we'll also have to make the default
case
that is if the user selects 5 6 or any
other number that is not in the menu
then we will display a message saying
that
please select from the options given
above
so before that we'll add the slash d
please select
from the options
given above
after that we'll use slash n
and n
after that we'll call the main function
so that the control goes back to the
main function
we'll also use
system
cls that is clear screen
it means every time the code is
processed it will clear up the screen
now all we need to do is to create the
login function
so
i'll write void
login
and inside this function first of all
we'll create some variables
and so let's do that and count
user
id
no this user id would be of string
write
string
user id
then there would be
password
then id
then pass
all right so these are the variables
that we have created
now again we'll use this
system cls
that is clear screen
we have to
write cls inside the double quotes
all right now we will display a message
that please enter the username and
password
so we'll do that
and we'll write slash g slash d slash d
and
please enter
the username
and
password
all right now
will again display a message saying that
username
now we'll take the input
here user id
is the username that the user will enter
now again we will display a message
saying that password
let's make it capital
again we'll take the input
now as the user has entered the username
and password
now we will check that if that username
and password already exist in our
records
and for that we will use the file
handling operation
of if stream class because if stream is
used
to read the data
so
we will use if stream
and if stream class
this will read the data from the file
input is the object name
and
the file name would be
records
dot txt
all right
we'll have to
[Music]
make it inside the double quotes
all right
so now this if stream will check inside
the file that if that login password
exists or not
and to check that we will have to use
the while loop
inside the while loop will write
input that is the object name
then there would be id
and then
pass
so this is the id and password
and this is how we read in file handling
operations
here what we are doing is we are reading
that if
that id and password is there and then
we will match those id and password
with
the id and password that is entered by
the user
so for that we will have to use the if
condition inside the while loop
so let's do that
we will write if
id equals user id
and
pass equals password
then
count would be
one
and then we will use system cls to clear
the screen
here we have assigned one to count
because in the next part we will use an
if condition
that if the count is one then we will
display a message saying that
your login is successful that is the
password or username entered by the user
matches with the record that is
the user has already registered
so now before that we have to close this
file
so
let's do that
we'll to close this file we will use the
object name that is input dot
close this is how we can close the file
all right now we'll use the if condition
and inside this if condition
as i have said if count equals one
all right if count equals one
then we will first of all display the
user id that is the username
and then we will display a message that
your login is successful
so let's do that
your login
is successful
now thanks for logging in
now again we will
shift the control to the main because
there is the main menu
and now
inside the else block
we will display a message
that is if the user and password is not
found inside the file
then
it means that the
user is not registered so he can't login
he has to register first
so we'll
display message
saying that
login error
please check your username
now again
main function now we have to create
another function that is the
registration function
that is if the user press 2 then this
registration function
would be called
so let's create this function
void registration
now inside this function we will
first of all create some variables then
after that we'll ask the user to enter
the username and password pretty much
the same as that of the previous
function so first of all string
r for registration
user
id
our user id
then r
password
then rid and r pass
system cls again clear screen
all right
now we will
display a message saying that enter the
username
again
enter the password
our password
all right
so in the previous function we have used
if stream class but in this function we
will use off stream class because we
want to write inside the file and off
stream helps us with that
so
for that we will use off stream
and object name would be f1
and
records is a file
and we will use the
app mode
this ios mean the input output stream
and app will open the file and append
the output in the end
so this is our app mode there are
different modes
so here we are using this app mode
so after this we'll put the semicolon in
the end
now
we have to write inside the file so
we'll do the
f1
and this is how we write inside the file
f1 here is the object name
and our user id
is the username and after that we'll add
some space
and then
our
password
that is the password
we want some space between the username
and password that is why we have
used the single quotes and
this is how we write inside the file and
after that we'll again use the system
cls that is the clear screen
all right
now we'll display a message that
registration is successful
as we have already written inside the
file so now we can display this message
saying that registration is successful
now again control back to the main
function
so now we will create the forgot
function
this is the last function
void
forgot
so
this function
would be called when the user
forgots the password or username
so first of all we will create a
variable
option
now we will ask the user that you forgot
your password no worries then we'll ask
the user to press one to search your id
by you by your username and press two to
go back to the main menu
so let's start
before that we will use system cls
all right now we'll display the message
saying that
you forget the password
no worries
and then
new slashing
now press one
to search
your
id
by username
all right
now
press 2 to go back to the main menu
all right now after that
we'll use slash d
all right now enter your choice
now we'll take the input
c in
option
after that using the switch case
statement
option
now inside the switch case
you will create cases
so case one
that is when the user selects option one
then
int
we'll use bracket over here because
there would be
multiple lines
all right
now int
we'll initialize it with zero
now
some more variables we will declare the
string
s user id
and
s id
then s pass
so these are some string variables and
count is the integer variable after that
we'll display a message that enter the
username which you remembered
so let's do it
enter the username
you remembered
all right
now
we will take the input from the user
as user id
so once the user entered the username
then we will check
that if that username exists in the file
using the if stream object as we know
stream is used when we want to read from
the file or check from the file
so we'll create the if stream class
and the object name would be f2
and
records.txt is the file
all right now using the while loop
we will check
that if
the username
is there inside the file or not
so s id
and s pass
so now
if
s id equals
s
user id
then
count equals one
so we will assign one to count and
after that we will close the file that
is f2
dot close
so here what we are doing is we are
checking inside the file using the
stream object that if that id or
password is there and if that id is
there then we'll assign one to the count
as initially it was zero and then again
we'll do the same as that we have in the
pre as we have done in the previous
function that if count equals to one
then we will print a message that your
account is found
so let's do that
so as we have closed the file now after
that
we'll use an if statement
with a condition that if
count equals 1
then we will print a message saying that
your account is found
your password is
s pass
so it will display the password
again the control will be shifted to the
main
where there is the main menu
and inside the else block now
inside the else block will
display a message
saying that
sorry your account is not found
sorry
your account
is not
found
so as the case one ends we will use the
break statement
now we will create case 2.
in case 2 as we have
said that it will simply call the
go back to the main menu so
all we'll do is
call the main function
so that the control will go back to the
main menu
and also we have to create the default
case
in the default case we'll simply print a
message saying that wrong choice please
try again
so we'll use slash d slash d slash d
wrong choice
please try again
after that
we'll call the forgot function
so that the user can try again with the
correct option all right so
we forgot to save this
so let's name it as
register
dot cpp
and save it
now let's try to run this
go to execute and compile and run
there is some error
all right so it must i must be capital
as we have declared
let's try again
so as you can see welcome to login page
this is the menu and this is press 1 to
log in press 2 to register press 3 if
you forgot your password press 4 to exit
so now we will enter our choice first of
all we need to register so we'll write 2
and our username as
sam
addrete
email
this is our username
and now our password
sam123
is our password
so as we can see the message
registration is successful
after that we will log in
as we have registered now we'll try to
log log in
sam address email is our username
and sam
one two three
our password so as you can see your
login is successful
thanks for logging in
now let's say i forgot my password
so i'll press three as
if you forgot your password you have to
press three
so
there's a message you forgot the
password no word is please
press one to search your id by your
username so i'll press one
now i'll write my username the last
username i remembered
sam at the rate
email
so your account is found your password
is this as you can see
so let's say
again if i forgot the password and by
chance
i write
sammy
at the rate email
then sorry your account is not found is
displayed
as sam address email is the registered
customer and not sami address email so
it will display this message that sorry
your account is not found
and let's
say again if we try to
press let's say 5
then we can see that please select from
the options given above actually we have
to make it below options given below
but we can do that
else everything is working fine so now
we will click on exit that is 4
and this is the message thank you
so as you can see this is our
registration and login
system in c plus and this is how we can
do it
we have created these three functions
that is login function
then there is registration function
after that there is a forgot function if
we forgot the password and the code is
pretty easy and not that much long so
you can try this code on your own so in
this session we will learn how to create
a supermarket billing project in c plus
we will create this project in small
parts as there are various functions
that we will be creating for this
project
like the add function to add the goods
and products in the market and delete
function to delete some products etc
also we will create a buyer site where
the buyer can buy the products or food
items of his choice
now we will move to our code editor that
is devc plus
so now let's create a new file
and we'll start with
adding the header files
first of all we'll add hash include
iostream
then we'll include the fstream file
right hash include f stream because here
we have to do the file handling
operations as well so we'll add the
stream file
now we'll write the namespace standard
now let's save this one and name it
billing one dot cpp
all right so we have named this file
now first of all we'll create a class
and we will declare some variables and
functions
so let's create a class and name the
class as
shopping
inside the class shopping first of all
inside
the private scope
we will create or declare some variables
p
code then
float type
price
then another variable discount of load
type
then
name which would be string
all right let's name it p name
p stands for product
all right
now inside the public scope we will
declare the functions
so
let's name this function as menu
because we have to create the menu then
administrator function
all right now let's create a buyer
function
a buyer customer whatsoever
all right
now let's create add function
then the edit function
these definitions of these functions we
will create later first of all here we
are declaring these functions
after that we have to remove some
products for that we will create remove
function
and then the list function to display
the list
and at last
recept function
all right so here we have declared the
functions and the variables
so now we'll put semicolon in the end of
the class
and we'll start with the first function
that is the menu function
so we'll write void
class name
then the scope resolution operator
and
menu function
so now inside this function
first of all we will create a
variable
that is choice
and
some more variables like let's say
email
and password
because here we will need email as well
as password for the login purpose
so now we have to create this menu and
for that we have to first of all display
supermarket main menu and after that we
will display that administrator buyer
etc and
all that so now let's start with that
for that we have to display
and
you can display in your own style like i
usually do like this
slash t to add some horizontal space
it's just for formatting
and
after that same will do
to save some time let's just copy and
just paste it
and but now we'll here we'll write
supermarket
main menu
reduce some space
all right now similarly we'll do here
now let's just copy and paste this part
all right now again some space
alright now we'll create a menu in which
the user have to select the customer
have to select
whether he is an administrator or a
buyer
so let's do that
and for that
write c out
slash d slash d slash d to add some
horizontal space
and
all right now
administrator
now similarly here we'll do for
we'll add some space over here
just remove this one
in number two we'll write buyer
the person who wants to buy stuff
from the market
all right
now
let's format it
we'll add some space over here
now in number three we'll write exit
all right it's pretty much done
after that again if we want to add some
space we can
add some
it's just for formatting purposes you
can do it in your own way
and after that
we have to display a message saying that
please select
so we'll display message
forgot to use semicolon
now we'll take an input from the user
that
whatsoever he wants to click on like if
he is an administrator he'll click on
one if he's a buyer then he'll click on
two and if he wants to exit he can click
on three
so we will take an input of choice
now we have to use switch case
and let's create that
switch inside this will write choice we
all know how switch case works
all right now for case 1 that is
administrator case
we will ask the user to enter the login
credentials if he or she is an
administrator
so let's just do that
so first of all we'll display a message
saying that please login
so
slash d slash d
enter email and then
we'll take the input of email we already
declared this variable
email
and
now
we'll take the password from the user
now we'll take the input of the password
so as we have taken the email and
password from the user now we will set
an email and password that only admin
knows and no other person can enter that
and let's say
for that we have to use if else
statements
so
if
email
equals
now let's set the email first of all
robbie at the rate email.com
you can write the email and password as
of your choice
and i'll set the password now as
robbie at the rate one two three
now inside the if block
if the user enters this that means it is
the administrator
and we will call this administrator
function
all right
now in the else block
we'll simply display a message saying
that invalid username password
invalid username
invalid email password
all right after that we'll use the break
to end the case
now we will create case 2
case 2 is for the buyer so we'll write
case
2
and in this case we'll simply call the
buyer function
so this is the case 2 and now we have to
create the case 3.
inside the case 3
case 3 is for exit so we'll do exit 0
it means successful termination of the
program
now default case
so inside the default case will simply
display a message saying that
please select from the given options
default case will execute if a person
selects any other option
rather than one two three
so
we'll have to instruct him
that please select from the given option
select from the
given options
now
after this we'll use a go to statement
after the switch statement
so go to is a jump statement
so it will help us in jumping to the
main menu again
after the completion of this switch case
and
this m is a label we have to put this
label at the starting of this
menu
so let's do that
right m
now coming back to the next function
so this function is done
so we will close this function
all right so now we will create an
administrator function in which there
will be different
options inside the administrator menu so
now let's start with that
so we will write
void
shopping that is the class name
stroke resolution operator
administrator
so our function name is administrator
so inside this function
first of all we will declare variable
choice
now after that
we will create a menu in which there
will be different options
so
let's do that
first of all we'll write slash in
then slash d
some horizontal spaces
so that
administrator
menu
all right
after that
here will be our first option
so first of all we'll write slash and
then slash these
just to make it bit fancy we can do this
add the product
so the user can select this option if he
wants to
add the product not user the
administrator
now we will add some space in this one
now again same
we'll copy it from here then paste it
so here we will change it to the
modified product
modify the product and
we have to adjust it as well
all right now again we'll add some space
we can copy this one
now
here we write delete the product
now here again
three and make this four
four will be off back to main menu
all right
now after that we will ask the user to
please enter your choice
so we'll display a message saying that
please enter your
choice
all right
now the user
will enter the choice
now again we have to use the switch
case statements
inside this
first case first of all we'll
make and inside this first case
we will call the add function
after that we'll use break statement
now we'll create case 2.
in case 2 we will call the modify
function or the edit function
so we'll write
edit
and again the break
now
we'll create case three
in case 3
there will be delete function
so we'll name this function as remove
rem stands for remove
now case 4 would be back to main menu
so for that
we'll simply call the menu function
now after case 4 there would be default
case
so we'll write default
and we'll print a message saying that
invalid choice
all right so
after the switch case statement again as
we have done in the previous function
we will mark
m with the go to statement which is a
jump statement
and label it over here
all right so administrator function is
done
after this function now we will create
another function let's say buyer
function
so for that
void shopping
scope resolution operator
buyer
all right so inside this buyer function
first of all
we'll declare the variables
and choice
now inside this function will ask the
user that he or she wants to buy the
product or go back so let's create that
first of all here we'll write
by the product no first of all we'll
write buyer
yeah
after that
let's get some space
now
first would be
my product
now there is let's copy it and paste it
over here
and
space
[Music]
all right so these are some options
after that we will ask the user to enter
your choice
then the user will enter his choice
so we are taking the input
after that
we'll use the switch statement
and choice
so inside the switch statement first of
all we'll create case one
inside this case
we will call
the receipt function
inside the recept function all the
operations of the buyer will take place
so this is the receipt function and
after that we'll use break
now we'll create case 2
in case 2 will write
or call the menu function as
2 would be go back as you can see
now default case
write invalid choice
now after this again we'll use the go to
jump statement
and mark here m
all right so after this function
now we will create the add function
so as we know if the user over here
the administrator over here will click
on this add the product that is the
first
case then this add function will be
called so now we will create this add
function
so we'll write void
shopping
at
so inside this function we will use some
file handling operations
so
create an object of fstream class
so data is the name of the object
now we'll create some variables like in
c
and
token equals zero
and
float
p
float
d
and
string n
so these are the variables that we have
declared now we have to create a menu
kind of a structure in which we will ask
the user to enter the product code of
product the name of the product price
discount etc
so let's do that
so let's write
add new
product
all right after that we will write the
product code of product we'll ask the
user to enter the product code of the
product
so we'll write slash and slash in and on
slash d
we'll
take the input in p code we have already
declared these variables at the top of
our code
now
we will write
another
message saying that name of the product
for that
i'll write
name
of the product
now we will take the input
in pname
now we'll display
price of the product
we'll take the input in price
now we'll ask to enter the discount
so we'll write
discount of the
discount on the product
all right so
here we are asking the user to enter the
product code of the product and the user
will enter the product code then the
name of the product then he will enter
the name then the price and then the
discount
so after that
now we will have to open a file
because as this add option is being used
by the administrator so we have to store
these product details inside a
particular file so that we can display
to the user that we have these products
in our supermarket
all right so
for that
we'll have to use the file handling
operations
data is the name of the object as you
can see and with the help of data.open
we can open the file
and
the name of the file we can write here
database
dot txt
all right
after that
we want
to open this file in reading
mode ios in will open the file in
reading mode and ios out will open the
file in writing mode
so now
we will use if statement and will write
if not
data that is if this file
doesn't exist
then
inside this function will write
data dot open
database dot txt
we will open this basically we will open
this file in writing mode if this file
doesn't exist
and if this file exists then in else
block will do that
ios out ios app stands for append mode
and io sound out stands for write mode
now
in order to write inside the file
we'll give some space and
now we'll write
p code
this is how we can write inside a file
after that p name
then again some space
after that there is price
then again some space
after that
this for discount
then we'll
use slash n
all right so after that we have to close
the file as well right data.close
data.close after that
in else block
that is if the file exists
then
we will read from the file so this is
how we can read from file
and
p
d these are the variables here we are
initializing the file because after that
we have to use the while loop to iterate
through the file
so let's do that
first of all i'll write this part and
then i'll explain
inside this will use if statement
and
if c equals to p code
then
token will be incremented
and
for
initialization
or for iteration
we will again do that
so here what we are doing is first of
all we are initializing the index of
file here we are initializing the index
because after that we will use the while
loop inside this while loop
we have written
not data dot eof this eof is the end of
file function
this while loop will make sure to check
every content of the file
by iterating it so one by one each
content of the file is checked if the
code matches with the p code that is if
there is a duplicacy then
the token variable which we have
we can see initialize with 0 will be
incremented
it will become 1 basically after that
for the iteration purpose
we are reading from the file
and after that now
we will close the file
data dot close
all right
now
we'll use if statement that if token
is one as we know
if token gets incremented that is if
there is a duplicacy
then again
it will go back to the menu
that is if the product code entered
by the administrator already exist then
he have to enter another product code
because if
the administrator enters the duplicate
code then it will again go back to this
menu
so this go to m
we have to label it over here
all right now in the else block
that is
if
the token value is not incremented
that is the product code entered by the
administrator is unique and not
duplicate then we can enter the prod
the product that is its product code its
product name its price
so for that we can just copy paste this
part
it's the same
and
we can paste it over here
so here we are writing inside the file
so this is how we can write inside the
file and here we are opening the file in
append and writing mode
to write inside the file we have to open
the file in writing mode
so after that
we will display a message saying that
record inserted
this bracket error the else block
will close over here
all right
now this add function is done
we have done this part
now we have to create another function
named the edit function
as the add function is used for adding
the products in the market
based on their price
names discounts etc now edit function
will edit the products like if you want
to edit some product like
choose instead of milk or something like
that you can do it with the help of edit
function so we'll do that functionality
in edit function
so let's do that
we'll write void
shopping
edit the name of the function
so inside this function we will create
two
objects
of fstream class
that is data one and data two
that is data and data one
all right
so these two are the objects of a stream
class
now we will
declare some variables
or string n
all right
now we'll write
a message displaying modified the record
so write slash in
now we will ask to enter the product
code
so we'll write
now we will open the file and check if
that file exists or not
now
if that file doesn't exist
then
we'll simply display a message
saying that file doesn't exist
and in else block
we will open the file
but not the same file the other file
this
file would be database one and we will
open this file with the help of this
object that is datavan
so we'll write
data one dot open
the name of the file would be
database
one dot
txt and we will open this file
in
band mode
and
writing mode
so here what we are doing is we will
save our edited data
in this file and we will rename it to
the original name that is
database.txt
the name of this file is database1.ext
we will save the edited data in this
file and then
we will rename this file as database.txt
that is the original name of the file
so now we will write
data
p code
then p name
price
and then
this
so we are initializing this file
basically we want to iterate this file
so
not data dot end of file
it will check each and every content of
the file
all right now
using if statement
we will check if p key equals to p code
p key is the code that is entered by the
administrator
which he wants to edit
so if that
matches then inside the file
write slash n
slash t slash t
then product
of new code
product new code
here we are asking the administrator to
enter the new code for the
product
so
cnc
he or she will enter the code then we
will ask
to enter the name
so write slash and slashing
name of the
product
p name
and
now the
price so we'll write
now the discount
now all the updated details of the
product will be entered with the help of
data1 object
again some space
then
n
again some space
and here p
then here
d
all right
now
we'll write
a message saying that record edited
record edited all right
after that we'll increment the token
that is token plus plus
now
this was the if block now in else block
gain data one
that is if
the product key or the product code
entered by the administrator doesn't
matches with
any of the product code within the file
then
the old variables that is
p code
p name
price
and after that discount
that is this
all right after that
yeah
we'll do that slashing
now outside this else block we'll write
that
code p name
just for increment purpose
we want the while loop to iterate so
that is why we will use this one
so that this while loop can iterate
all right after this
we will close both the objects that is
data
dot close we are closing both the files
and data1
dot close
now as i already discussed that we have
to rename that database 1 back to the
original name that is database so we
will use two
functions in c plus
that is
remove function and rename function with
the help of remove function we will
remove the list that is the database.txt
file we will remove the database.txt
file and then with the help of rename
function we will rename database1.ext to
database dot txt
so let's do that
remove inside remove we will write the
name of the file
it will basically remove all the list
inside the file
all right now rename function
inside the rename function first of all
we have to write the old name
that is database
1 dot txt
then the new name
that is database
dot txt
so now
using this function
this name will be changed to database
dot txt
all right
now
if
token value is not incremented
or we can say is 0
then
it will display a message saying that
record not
found
sorry
and with that we are done with the
edit function
and now we will create
remove function
so we'll write
void
shopping
rem remove
this remove function will be bit similar
to that of the edit function
so now let's start with that
f stream
will create two
objects
data and data one
now
hint p key
and
into token
we'll initialize it with
zero now
will display
slash d
delete
product
now we will display
to enter the product code so we'll write
similar to previous function
now data dot
open database
dot txt
we are opening this file
in reading mode
and then we will check
if this file exists or not so write
so here we will write
if
not
data
then inside will display
file doesn't exist
all right
now in else block
inside the else block we will open the
data1 file
and the file name would be database one
dot txt
and we will open this file
in append and writing mode
all right now after that
a vsp code to initialize or iterate
the while loop
we will write this
this is how we read from the file
and here we will use data because we
will
i trade through data.eof
that is data file
now inside the while loop
again we'll do the same as that we have
previously done
data dot eof end of file
now
use if
p code
equals to
p key
then
we'll simply display the message saying
that
product
deleted
successfully
all right and now we will increment the
token
now in the else block we will write
data one
space
then p code
then p name then price then discount
now
rename
then
price
and discount
here the p key entered by the
administrator will check for the first
product code if it matches the if block
executes
in the second iteration it will not
match and else block will execute and
database 1 file will be displayed
in other words in else block all the
products will be displayed except the
one which you want to remove or delete
so we will show this file database 1 and
then rename it with the previous one
that is database
all right so now let's go ahead
we'll do the same in order to white rate
this while loop
now
as we've done previously
data don't close as we have to close the
files
data 1
dot close
and after that again the remove function
to remove the database file
and rename function
firstly we will write the database one
that is the old name
make sure to put semicolons then
database
then
database
dot txt the new name
all right after that if
token is not incremented
that is if token is zero
then it will simply
display a message
saying that record cannot found
or record not found
so as we have created three major
functions
now we will create another function
named list
it will help us in showing the list to
the customer or the buyer
all right shopping
now i will write
list
inside this function
write
the data
the object of the stream class
then data dot open
will open the database file
dot txt
in the
reading mode
all right after that
we will format it a bit
so after that again
we have to write the product number name
price etc so we'll write
product number
and then
we can use slash d
again name
then
price
and then we'll use selection
please put them inside the double quotes
and now again we'll copy this part
can design it in your own way
and
now we can do
the reading part
data
p code then rename
as we have done previously
price
this
while loop inside the while loop again
we'll use
not data
dot eof
now inside this file
we'll write the product code
product name and the price we'll start
with product code
then
product name
that is p pname
after that
price
for the iteration purpose we'll write
again p code
p name
price
discount
all right now after that we will close
the file by writing data dot
close
all right so we are done with this
function as well after this now we will
create the receipt function in which all
the customer operations will take place
so now let's create this
recept function so we'll write void
shopping
r e c i p t recept
and now inside this function first of
all we'll create
the object of f stream class
then we'll declare some arrays because
we have to store multiple product keys
and multiple quantities of those
products
so that is why here we have to use
arrays
and then we will declare some variables
so let's start
first of all f stream class the object
of this class is
data
now after this we'll create
array
array c means array of codes
so i'll declare it in that way
now after that
now we'll declare another array array of
q that is quantity
now
choice variable
then there would be
a counter variable let's say
then discount variable
we'll initialize it with zero
and we'll initialize amount with zero as
well
all right now
total variable
now we will display a message
saying that
receipt so that the user will know that
this is the receipt
now after that we will open a file
that is data.open will open the
database.txt file and then we'll check
if that file or database exist or not
so
we have done this previously data.open
database
dot
txt will open this file in
reading mode
now we'll use if block and inside this
if block will write not data we are
checking that if this file or database
exists or not
all right
if it doesn't exist if not data that is
if this file doesn't exist or this
database doesn't exist then we will
print the message saying that
empty database
empty with a p
now as
this now in else block will write if
that file exists
then first of all we will close the file
that we already opened
now in else block we will call this
list function that we have created
because if the file is created then we
have to call the list function and
will show the user or the customer that
these are the products available in the
supermarket
and for that we are calling this list
function
now we will
design the structure and ask the user to
place the order
so let's do that
please place the order
now again we'll copy this part
all right so now
we'll use
do while loop
the purpose of using this do while loop
is that we have to run a specific part
of the code every time and the other
part of the code we have to run based on
the choice
so now let's start with that
inside the do
block
first of all we will
ask the user
to enter the product code and enter the
product quantity
so first of all
we'll write
product code
enter product code
we'll take the input in the array
now we'll ask the user
to enter
the quantity
all right now
we'll take the product quantity let us
see in
a r r
q
see
now
we will check that
if the product code entered by the user
matches with the product code
that is being already entered
then we will display a message saying
that duplicate product code please try
again
so for that we have to use the for loop
first of all and inside the for loop
we'll initialize i with 0 i less than
c we have already initialized c with
zero
now
i plus plus
so inside this
for loop use if condition and check if
the product key or product code entered
by the user matches with
the product code that already exists in
the file then we will display a message
saying that duplicate product code so
we'll
write if
a c of
c that is entered by the user
equals array of c
i
so i will keep on iterating as we have
used for loop
so inside this if we will display a
message saying that
duplicate product code
please
please try again
all right
now
we'll write go to m
again jump statement as we have already
discussed
now after this
we will increment c plus plus
that is
if the product
key is not duplicate then c will
increment that is the counter will
increment
all right now
we will display a message saying that do
you want to buy another product or not
right
all right so as we have displayed this
now we will take the input of the user
see in choice that whether he wants to
buy the product or not
so this is our do loop
now we'll have to use after this do
block we'll have to use while loop as we
are using the do while loop now here is
the condition that if the user will
press yes that is y
then
this
loop will execute
all right
now
we'll make a design structure so we'll
write c out
and slash and slash and slash t slash t
slash t
and now we'll write receipt
all right now after that
now we'll write product number
sorry by mistake we write
capital n now we'll write product number
then now we'll write
product quantity
product name sorry
now
product quantity
then the price
now we'll use the for loop to iterate
through the file so we'll write
4 into i equals 0 i less than c i plus
plus
so now inside this for loop first of all
because we have to do the iteration we
will open the file data.open
database
double quotes database dot txt
and we'll open this file in reading mode
so ios
in
alright so after that
we will kind of initialize this file
we'll write p code
p name
then
price
after that there was discount
all right
now as we have done previously while not
data
dot eof that is end of file
and inside this while loop we will check
we are actually matching if the code
entered by the user that is ar r c i is
equal to the code present in the file
and if so
then we will do the calculations and add
those file in the customer basket
so let's do that p code equals
array of c of i
here we are checking
if so
then
we'll do the amount amount equals to
price of the product into the quantity
of the product
all right after that we'll have to do
the discount part
so in this part we know that
the discount is calculated by
multiplying amount with discount divided
by 100
and then we have to subtract it from the
amount
so let's do that amount minus
amount
into
discount
divided by 100
all right
now after that as we are done now we'll
have to add discount to the total
variable
because
in this part
the total amount
after getting discount is stored in this
disk variable now we will add this
variable to the total variable
all right so as this is done now we will
print this part so in this part we are
just printing so we'll
do the slash n and now
then p code
then p name
then
array of qo5
array of q
i
right now after that price
then amount
and amount after discount
or we'll write discount only
because we have to write the variable
all right now we'll have to add the
slash t's in between them
so let's do that part
all right so we have added the slash
keys in between them for the formatting
purpose now to iterate the file for that
rating purpose we'll do the same that p
code
name
price
discount
all right now
after this while loop
now we will have to close the data file
so write
data dot close
so after this data don't close we have
to print the total amount so let's do
that first of all we'll do some
designing part like let's say selection
session
now
just for design purpose
i will simply print the total variable
we'll write first of all total amount
now the variable
total
all right so everything is done except
the main function now in the main
function
we'll write
so int main
now inside this main function as we know
we have created the class shopping class
so we will create the object of that
shopping class and we will call
the menu function with the help of that
object as we know that is the first
function that must be called so we'll
write shopping
and let's say the object of this is
s
and s dot
menu function
so as we know the menu function is the
top most function
so this
menu will display when we run the file
so now everything is done
and now let's run this file
let's press compile and run
i hope it works
there are some errors
all right so 335 okay
so this is the error and now
57 line
line number 57
yeah we have to use double equal to
and one more error is there i think
now let's try to run this
there might be some more errors
as you can see
all right after this 386
okay so we haven't labeled this one
we have to label m
now let's try to run this
so here we can see supermarket main menu
first is administrator
then second if you are a buyer three to
exit
so first we'll login as an administrator
so as you can see please log in
so now we'll enter the admins
email
so we'll write
robbie
at the rate
email
dot com
now the password
robbie
one two three
now this is the administrator menu as
you can see first is the add product if
you want to add the product second to
modify the product three to delete the
product and flow to back to main menu
so now i'll click on
like i want to add the product so i'll
write one i'll press one and enter add
new product so now i have to add product
code of the product
like let's say the product of code of
product is one
name of group product let's say juice
and price is
70
and discount on product is
two percent record inserted
now again
i want to add so i'll click on one
product code of product would be two
now name of product would be let's say
bread
price
30
discount again two
record inserted now again product now
would be
let's say butter
three
butter
price of product would be
sixty discount would be four
now fourth product
sorry add product now product could be
fourth
and this would be
let's say x
price would be 170
discount
three percent
record inserted
so now we will check that these records
are inserted or not
so we can cross check it by
going here and open this database file
so as we can see one juice
product code one is juice
price is 70 2 is the discount
then second is bread third is butter
four is egg so first this is the product
code this is the price and this is the
discount on that product
now let's come back and modify the
product
let's say first product was juice
and we want to modify that product
so what we'll do is we'll add the
product code 1 and the new product code
would be
1 only let's say we don't want to change
that
and name of the product would be
chips
we'll replace it with chips
price would be
20
and discount would be two percent
so record edited as we can see
here record edited and now we can check
so now we'll open this database file so
as you can see
as you can see one chips
two bread three butter four eggs so the
first product that was juice is replaced
by chips
so this function is done now let's try
the delete function
we'll click on three for delete
and now we have to enter the product
code of the product which we want to
delete
so let's say we want to read the fourth
product
and we can see product deleted
successfully we can check that
as you can see
there are three products left the fourth
one got deleted
so now let's go back and let's check if
the customer wants to buy the product
how can he or she buy so let's first of
all we click on phone to go back to them
so now let's click on two as a buyer to
buy some products
now we'll click on one to buy the
product
so as you can see our products are chips
bread and butter
so product numbers are one two three and
their price are 20 30 60 respectively
and now we will enter the product code
of the product which we want to buy so
i'll click on one
and the quantity i say 2
want to buy another product or not they
are asking if you want to buy another
product if yes then press y and if no
then press n
so we'll click on y because we want to
buy another product so now i'll click on
two that is bread
product quantity i'll add product
quantity as four breads
and now butter so for that first of all
why
for butter i will click on three
product code of butter is three now
quantity would be two
now i don't want to buy any other
product so i'll click on n
so as you can see
product numbers product name their
quantity price amount and amount with
discount
and the total is there that is 272
and if we wish to buy another product so
we can click on one else we can click on
two to go back
so this is our recept our total amount
is there
so this is our complete project on
supermarket billing in c plus you can
try it although the code is bit long
approx 400 to 450 lines of code
but it is worth trying this project will
allow a user to book a flight to a
particular country and he or she will
receive the ticket by filling in all the
important details
different concepts of c plus will be
used in making this project
which will help you in understanding the
concepts of c plus in a practical manner
so now let's go ahead
so now let's go to our code editor that
is dev c plus plus
so this is our code editor and now let's
create a new file
and let's start with it
so let's add some header files
hash include
iostream
now we will add another header file that
is f stream
for file handling operations
now hash include
i o manip
so this header file is used for floating
point values so now we'll add the
standard namespace
now we'll write the main function
now inside this main function we will
create an object of a class
our class name is management
and
the object name would be
m obj
after that return 0
now we have to create this class
so we'll write
class
management
and inside this class
we will make a constructor because we
have created the object of this class so
constructor would be called and inside
that constructor we will call the
function
so let's do that first of all we'll
write the public scope
now under this public scope we'll write
management
so this is our constructor management
and inside this constructor we will call
a function let's say the name of the
function is main menu
all right
so now the class ends so we'll write the
semicolon in the end
now inside this function
main menu we have to create a menu that
will display on the screen
and also we have to use this function
many times inside this
program so we have to declare this
function globally so we'll write
void
mean
menu
so this is the function prototype
now after that
we can create this function
so let's write
void
main menu
and
now we'll declare some variables
l choice
and s choice
and another variable let's say back
now we have to create a layout or a
structure for a menu
so let's do that
slash t
airlines
you can write any name as of your choice
now we will write main menu
write slash d
now again we'll add some space
for some lines
let's add slash d
now we'll create a structure in which
we'll ask the user to press a particular
button to open a particular
functionality like press want to open
the customer details press 2 for flight
registration press 3 for ticket and
charges
so let's do that
now i'll copy paste
i'll copy this part and
paste it over here
and second one we'll write press 2
for flight registration
so
so we are done with the layout now we'll
take the input from the user
so let's do that
now we'll write l choice the variable
that we have declared
now for all three of them we'll make a
separate classes that is for customer
details we'll make a detailed class for
flight registration we'll make a
registration class for ticket and
charges will make a ticket class
and to to call the functions of these
classes we'll have to make the object of
these classes
so let's do that
so we'll write
details
d
d is the object name
registration
r r is the object name
ticket is the class name t is the object
name so we have created these objects
d r and t
now we'll use a switch statement
a switch case statement
and now we'll write
l choice
now inside the switch case first of all
we will create a case one
now inside this case we'll
have to call a function of detail class
so let's do that but before that we'll
write
see out
customers
so that it looks nice now we'll call the
function let's say the name of the
function is information
and now
we'll ask the user
to press one to go back to the main menu
like if the user wants to go back to the
main menu
after filling the details or something
like that
then
he or she can click on this one button
all right now we'll take the input
back this is the variable that we have
declared
now
if
back equals 1
then
we'll call the main menu function
that is the main menu will display
and also in else block will do the same
we'll call this function only
and here we'll write
press any
key to go back to main menu
now
here we'll do the break
case one ends
now we have to create a case two
case two is for flight registration so
we'll simply
display a message and call the function
we'll write
book a
flight
using this system
all right after that we'll use slashing
and handle
all right now we'll call this function r
dot flights r is the name of the object
and flights is the name of the function
that we will create afterwards
now we'll write
break
now we'll have to create case three
now cases for ticket collection
now all we need to do is to display a
message saying that get your ticket
all right now we'll use slash n
now we'll call the function
t is the object name
bill is the name of the function
let's say
now
we'll display a message saying that your
ticket is printed
you can get it
or you can collect it
now we'll write press 1 to display your
ticket
we'll take the input and
if back equals to one
then
inside if condition
we'll call this function
display
t is the object name displays a function
now after that we'll display a message
press 1 to go back to main menu
or press any key to go back to main menu
so we'll write
press
any key to go
back
to main menu
all right now after that we'll take the
input of this
and if back equals to
1
then we'll
write main menu that is we call this
menu function
and in else
we gone
again we will call this menu function
to display the menu
right after this
break to end the case
closing bracket and now here is the
starting bracket
all right so now we have to create a
case for
inside case 4 first of all we'll display
a message saying that see out thank you
because in case 4 as we can see
press 4 to exit so
if a user press 4 will display a message
saying that
this is slash inflation and then again a
slash t
now
thank you message will be displayed
after that endl
no
now we'll write break
and after that
there would be a default case
now in this default case a message would
be displayed like
invalid input or something like that
right
invalid input
please try
again
right after that we'll use slash n and
handle
now
to go back to main menu
so that the user can try once again so
we'll call this function main menu
now after that
break
now we have to create classes like first
of all we have to create this
detail class in which we are calling the
information function
so this is the information function and
now let's create its class that is class
detail
so let's do it
class
details
now in the public scope
you will declare some variables
and
static
string
name
and let's say gender
both of these would be string
and
now after that let's create the variable
phone number
and
gender
not gender age we have already created
gender
now age would be integer
then there is
address we'll write add
then there is another variable
static and
customer id
so let's see id
now
an array we have to create
let's give it hundred
now let's create this function
information
so inside this information function
first of all we'll ask the user to enter
the customer id so
slash n
enter the customer
id
after that
now the user will enter the customer id
c
i d
as you can see
now
will ask the user
to enter the name
then the name variable
then we'll ask the user to enter the
edge
then there is address
after that there would be
gender
now once the user has entered all these
details then we'll display a message
saying that
your details are saved with us
so we'll write your
details are saved
thus
[Music]
all right so we have to end the class
over here so we'll use semicolon
now we'll create another class
now we will create the registration
class but before that we have to use
some of the variables of the detailed
class in the ticket class
so for that
we'll write
in detail
scope resolution operator
c
id
this is the variable that we want to use
then the name variable
write string
name
then that variable
gender so let's string
all right so now we can create this
class
so let's do this right class
registration
and now inside this class first of all
we'll declare some variables under the
public scope
we'll write
we'll declare a static variable
choice
then
another variable that is choice one
let's say
then
another variable back
then
a static float variable
named charges
all right
so these are the variables now we have
to create the function flights that we
have called from the main menu function
so this is the flight function now
inside this flight function
there is a character array
named flight n
now after that
inside this array we'll put the name of
the countries as the elements so let's
start
first of all is dubai
after that there is
canada
then let's say another one is
uk
then there is
usa
after that there would be australia
then let's say europe
all right now
using a for loop
we will display each of these countries
one by one
so
we'll write int a equals zero
a less than
[Music]
six
a plus plus
now inside this for loop
we'll write
a plus one
dot
flight
two
so here what we are doing is
this a plus one that is zero plus one so
dubai will be displayed then one by one
canada uk us australia all of these
will get displayed and now after that
we'll write
flight n
and l
now
all these countries will be displayed to
the user
so now the user have to select a country
so first of all we'll write
welcome
to the
airlines
then
and after that
will ask the user to press the number of
the country of which you want to book
the flight
so we'll write
press the number
so we'll take the input from the user
see in choice
now after that
we'll use switch statements all right
switch
inside we'll write
choice
and now we'll make some cases
case one will be of dubai case two will
be of canada then uk us australia and
then europe
so let's start with dubai
so we'll display a message
will write welcome to dubai merits
all right now slashing
now again we'll display a message saying
that
your comfort
is our priority
enjoy the journey
now
we'll display following are the flights
following
are
the flights
alright
so now
we'll display first flight so right
this is the name of the flight and now
and l and now we have to display also
that the timing and the date of the
flight and how many hours will it take
and the price so let's do that
so here we'll write
slash d
then we'll write
the date
after that the timing
there is 10 hours flight
group is 14 000 let's say
similarly
let's copy and paste
let's say there are three flights
that are going to dubai
and
let's change the model numbers
658
and the time
and the date also
all right
so these are the flights now we will ask
the user to select the flight
all right
select the flight you want to book
[Music]
see in choice one
now if the user chooses one
then we have to create the condition
you can use the switch case or you can
do if else as well
so let's start if choice one
equals equals one
that is if the user or the customer
chooses the first flight flight then
charges
will assign
the flight charges
like 14 000
and
display a message
saying that you have successfully booked
the flight
[Music]
you can go back to menu and take the
ticket
will display this message
so this is our if statement
now we have to create else if statement
as well
for the condition we'll write if choice
one
equals equals two
then what we'll do is
let's just copy and paste to save time
we can copy this part and paste it over
here
charges as we know the charges of this
light is 10 000
it will write 10 000
and its number was
658
all right similarly
for the third flight as well we'll do
the same
the charges was 9 000
so let's do that
the number was 498
we have to change this one
let's say 508
so that the flight numbers are unique
now in else block
we'll write
invalid input shifting to the previous
menu so we'll simply display that
and then we will call the flights
function
after that
if the user wants to go back to the main
menu so we'll display a message for that
press any key to go back to the main
menu
[Music]
if the user chooses one that is if back
equals equals 1
then the main menu function would be
called
and same otherwise
similarly we'll create case 2
so let's do that
in case 2 we'll just copy and paste this
one to save some time
all right the changes we have to do is
welcome to canadian
airlines
and now your comfort is a priority
it's all right following other flights
so
the modern number and number of flights
we have to change
let's say
and the timings like
and the dates and time
it's
2 pm
you can change that as per your choice
you can do whatsoever you want
20 hours
then select the flight you want to book
then similarly in the first flight was
of 24 000.
ca198
and if you choose 2 then there would be
29 000.
forty thousand
the rest is all good shifting to the
previous menu as we have done previously
and now again
after this else
we can create
case three
so inside this case three we'll write
welcome to
uk airways so right
so now let's say to uk there are only
two flights
let's say there are only one flight
to uk
all right
uk
and its flight number is 798 let's say
and the timings are
and date is first of all 12
and the timing is 10 am
and it will take around 14 hours
14 hours and 44 000
rupees
select the flight you want to book
this is same
and here i have to change 44 000
all right so to uk there is only one
flight so we not need to create this
health if statements
so we can just cut it
and in else block the rest is same
so now after that
we have to create case three
sorry case four
and we can copy and paste this one as
well
so our fourth flight was of
us that is u.s airways
all right now we will change the name
right
us567
and
the dates
it's a choice
assign it 39 000 here and
there is 42 000.
after this
now case 5 would be of australian
airlines so we'll write case
5
and copy paste this part
and here we'll write
australian
airlines
so let's change we'll write
yes
and
698
timing date would be
18.
nine
forty four thousand
[Music]
so all right else everything is done in
this part
now we'll create case six
in case six
all we need to change is
welcome to dubai my rates and
we'll change it to european airlines
european airlines then will change its
name to
eu
498 instead of 498.98
and the date let's say two
time is 2 a.m
18 hours of flight and its price is 36
000.
31 000
10 am and
all right now we have to change its
model number as well
all right so you
8.98
and its price is 36 000.
its price is 37 000.
all right rest everything is done in
this part
now let's create the default case
all right
in the default case we will write
invalid input
please
no shifting to the main menu
and then we will call this main menu
function
i will write break
and close the switch statements
all right so this registration function
is done
it's pretty long as we have created six
cases
of all the countries named
dubai canada uk us australia europe
now only one function is
or class is left that is ticket class
so let's create this ticket class
all right so now after this registration
class we'll have to use the semicolon
so
now before this ticket class
we need to know that we have to use some
variables of registration class
and the details class in this ticket
class so we will do the multiple
inheritance and before that
let's do the same thing as we did
earlier
float registration because we have to
use these variables
so we'll write
the class name then scope resolution
operator
charges
is the variable then another variable
would be
choice
both of these variables is of
registration class so that is why we are
doing this
all right now we will start with the
class ticket
all right class
ticket
then we have to inherit both of these
classes that is we have to use multiple
inheritance
right public
registration
and then details
so here we are using the multiple
inheritance because we have to use the
variables of both of these classes in
this class ticket
now in the public scope
we'll start with the function that is
bill
void bill
and now inside this function first of
all we'll
declare a variable named destination
and we'll left it like this because
we have to assign
it
a choice that is being made by the
person who wants to travel to the
country
so now off stream as we know is used to
create or write information in the files
the object of is of stream is out f
we have created now
let's say the file is records.txt you
can name it as per your choice
in which the data
of the flights is being stored
now we'll write inside this
records.txt file
so as we know
to write inside the file the object name
and
then
whatsoever we want to
show inside the file
xyz airlines
take it
details that is class name scope
resolution operator
c id
then end l
similarly we'll do that for name and
gender as well
you
now
when it comes to destination as we have
left the empty space
now the user if the user will press
one then it will go to dubai if if two
then canada three then uk four then uss
we will have to do that as well
so we'll write if
registration as the class was
registration
scope resolution operator
choice equals equals one
then destination variable
equals
dubai
and
let's copy this part because we have to
use else if statements as well
you can just copy and paste all we need
to do is
else if now we can change it to choice 2
and name to canada
now after that
we'll simply print
or write the destination
so first of all we'll write destination
and then we'll print the
variable
let's do slash t to add some horizontal
space now
destination variable
all right now
we'll write the flight cost
because it is a variable of registration
class
all right now
we have to close this
object or file out f dot
close
we have closed the file now
we have to display the receipt as well
so for that we have to create another
function within this class only we'll
create void
disk bill that is display bin
so inside this function
we will create an if stream class and
it's variable let's say will be ifs we
all know it if stream class is used to
read from the file
so we are actually reading here so
we'll write records.txt file
now we'll use the if condition
inside this
so we'll write if
not ifs that if it doesn't exist
then it should show an error that is
let's say
file error
now if the file is there then we'll use
while loop
and we'll check not ifs dot end of file
that is here we are checking the file
till the end that is every content of
the file will check and ifs
dot
get line
array
100
here we have used get line to read the
content from the file and while loop
will help us in doing that after that
we'll print
array and then handle
all right after that we have to close
this file as well
so we'll do that ifs dot close
now we have to close the class as well
semicolon
so yeah our code is pretty much done
after this
there was main menu and
the main function
so now let's try to run this one
before that let's save it
and let's name it
as
flight
dot cpp
all right now let's try to run this
there are a few errors
all right so
first error is
this one and
let's check them all
flight dot cpp
66 line 66 there's an error
all right
function name is wrong flight we missed
the t
then
line 466.
in line 466
[Music]
where it is out f
we forgot right f
we missed the f and then
526
this one is associated with the previous
one error that is information error
let's go to 561
t dot display
all right so we
wrote the wrong name it was dis bill
all right now let's try to run this
again
semicolon we forgot
now
as you can see xyz airlines main menu
press one to add the customer details
there's a little bit formatting error
you can figure it out yourself
press one to add customer details press
two for flight registration three for
ticket and charges and photo exit so
let's say a new customer i am so i'll
press one and i'll write customer id
one
now the name of the customer let's say
raj
age of the customer is 23
and address is
chandigarh
all right
now gender is mail
now your details are saved with us
all right now press any key to go back
to the main menu we can press any key
two three one
then this is the main menu again
now i want to
register a flight i'll press two
so these are the flights fly to dubai
canada uk usa we forgot to add some
space we must add some space over here
so these are the flights to dubai canada
uk us australia europe and welcome to
airlines they are asking
us to press the number of the country of
which you want to book the flight let's
say i want to go to usa
so
four
so these are the flights us567 us658
us508
and these are the timings and these are
the dates let's say i want to go to
658 us 658 then i'll press 2
so there's a mistake by us we forgot to
change the name of this flight we'll
change this later and now let's go back
to the main menu
now let's say
we know that we have booked this u.s 658
but there was some
writing error we by mistake forgot to
write us 658 over here instead we write
dub
now as we know that we have this flight
that is booked so we want to go for
ticket and charges so we'll click on
three
your ticket ticket is printed you can
collect it
all right plus one
to display your ticket
as you can see
customer id1 customer name raj mail
description destination usa flight
course 39 000
as we know this is a 39 000 flight
so this is how
you can build this
project
and now let's correct our mistake
let's go to
australia
us flight sorry so here it is
let's change it to
us
and now let's save it
so now it will work fine
so this was a project on airline
reservation system
you can also try this project on your
own
indian premier league that is ipl is one
of the most popular and exciting events
in world cricket
ipl 2022 will begin on 26th of march so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held ipl auction data set
so in this video all the results and
insights that you will see are totally
based on the data we have collected from
kegel we will leave a link to the data
set in the description of the video you
can go ahead and download it for this
demo we'll be using python and jupyter
notebook to answer special questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so i'm on my jupyter notebook
and this is the file that we are going
to use
so here you can see i have
some of the cells already filled in
so this will save us some time and we
can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that i'll be using or the
ipython notebook
cool
so first let's go ahead and import all
the crucial libraries that will be
needed for our analysis so here you can
see i'm importing the pandas library the
numpy library these are for data
manipulation and numerical computation
then we have c bond and matplotlib for
data visualization
then
i have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the code
cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell
so here we will import
all the libraries okay it's done
now the next step is i'm going to create
a data frame in the name of ipl
and here i'm importing the data set
using the read underscore csb function
which is part of the pandas library so
pd here has been imported as pandas i am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is ipl
underscore 2022 underscore data set dot
csv is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have
successfully imported or loaded our data
set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so i'll use the head function
for this
ipl dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we'll
see how to drop this column apart from
that we have the name of the players the
base price at which the
player was sold or whether the player
was a draft pick so here rashid khan
from afghanistan pandya then we have
subman gill these are all
draft pick and then we have the
price at which
the players were listed in the ipl
auction then we have the
type of player whether the player is a
bowler an all-rounder a batsman
or
a wicketkeeper
then we have the cost in rupees this is
in crores so basically this column tells
us the
price at which the player was sold in
the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars
after that we have
2021 squad basically
this means
in last year's ipl where was the player
so here you can see rasit khan was
playing
for srh the sunrises hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for gujarat titans similarly hardik
pandya was playing for mumbai indians
for past few seasons
including 2021 but this season is going
to play for gujarat titans
so on and so forth
now
let's see the total number of players
that are present in the data set and the
total columns that are there for this
i'm going to use
the shape attribute so i'll write
ipl.shape
you can see here there are total 633
players that were part of the auction
and this includes the players who were
draft pick also
and there are total
eight columns in my data frame ipl
next
let's use the info function to check the
columns the data types and the total
non-null objects so i'll say
ipl dot info which is a function so i
have to use
brackets
there you go so here you can see it
saves total 633 entries from 0 to 632
data columns we have total eight columns
and then these are the
different
column names and
here you can see the total
non-null objects
present in the column
and here you can see the data types
and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the
data set so if i say ipl dot columns and
run it it will give me
all the different column names that are
present in the data frame
now as i said
the first column which is unnamed
colon 0 is
actually unnecessary so we are going to
drop it for that
we are going to use the
dot drop function and then i have passed
in my
column name followed by the axis on
which access is it there and then i say
in place equal to true which means it
will
replace
and permanently remove
they are named column from the data
frame so let's run it and now we'll
again check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the
unnamed column which was the first
column in the data frame and now we have
successfully removed it so player
becomes the first column in the data
frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so i'll say
ipl dot i'm going to use the is null
function
followed by this sum function
if i run this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values
similarly base price and type column
also don't have any null values but you
can see cost and rupees and
cost in dollars have
nearly 396
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
ipl auction and hence there was no price
associated
and then you can see there were a few
players who were not part of the ipl
squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the
rows that have
cost in dollar as null or nan so here i
have
used ipl and after that i am passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then i have used the is null
function
if i run this
you can
notice the
cost in
dollars column all these values are any
n or
null
and even the same
rows have
any n for cost in rupees as well
cool
now the
next task is to
fill these
null values or any n values with
zeros so for that i am going to use the
fill any function and here i have passed
in 0 so all the null values in the data
set will be replaced with 0
for
cost in
rupees column and
cost in dollars column
let me just run it
all right
okay
now
we will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means we will
check the rows that have null values for
the 2021 squad column
so what i'll do is i'll say
ipl
within
square brackets i'll say ipl and then
i'll pass in my
column name which is 2021 squad
and then after this i'll say dot
is null
so
this
cell
will give us
the unsold players in the 2021 auction
if i run this
you see
here you mark the 2021 squad column all
these players were unsold or did not
participate so hence it has any n values
all right
now what we are going to do is we will
replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 score column with
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with 0
here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
i'll say ipl
i'll pass in my column name which is
2021 squad
equal to
i'll say
ipl
2021
squad
dot
fill
any
which is the function and here i'll pass
in a
text or a string
saying not
participated
all right
let's run it
before that let me just scroll it down
now i'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again so
i'll just say ipl
dot
is null
and then i'm going to use this sum
function
if i run this
okay this is also a function cool now if
you see we have successfully removed all
the null values and replaced with either
zeros or not participated and hence now
you can see none of the columns in the
ipl data frame have null value so it
shows zero
great
now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called
status
which will hold two values
sold and unsold
but before that
we are going to
slice
our data frame so here i am looking for
all the rows where
cost in rupees
is greater than
zero
and those should be unique and
i'm storing the value in a variable
called teams so here you can see we have
the different teams where the
cost in rupees is greater than zero
now
i am going to create
another
column called status so i have written
ipl
within square brackets i am passing in
the column name which is status and
that will be equal to
the team
replaced by
sold value let me just run it and show
you the result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if i just say ipl
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players
so there are duplicate rows in the data
frame but here the names of the players
are same but in reality the players are
different
so
it is quite understood that
different players can have the same name
so
to get those names i am using the
duplicated function and i'll say keep
equal to false which means i don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see
lalitha we have
two entries so lalithyadev here is an
all-rounder
whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 ipl
and
last year
he was playing for the delhi capitals
and this year also
he is
sold
to delhi capitals
next we have
lalitha
who happens to be a bowler so this is
again different
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have amit mishra
who earlier used to play with the delhi
capitals but this time he remains unsold
so on and so forth so you can see two
entries for subham shrink and
all right
now
let's answer a very basic question
we are going to find out how many
players
have participated
in the 2022 ipl auction
for that we have already seen
the total number of rows that were
present but again i'm going to use the
shape function and within
square brackets i'm going to say 0 which
means it will give me the total number
of rows
and you can see 633 players were part of
the auction this is as per our data that
we have collected from kegel
up next we are going to find
how many types of players have
participated
so i'm going to say
types equal to
say ipl
i'll use the column name which is type
and i'm going to find the
count of
each type of players that are present in
the data frame
i'm going to use the values underscore
counts function
and then i'll say type
dot
reset underscore index
if i run it
okay there is an error here let me debug
the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types are not type
so let's run it
you can see here
we have the different
types of players so all rounders there
are total 242 all rounders are part of
the auction then we have 215 bowlers 112
batsmen's and 64 wicket keepers
now using the above table that we just
created
i am going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that i'm going to use the
matplotlib pi function so plt.pi
i'm using
dot values since i want
only the values from this table
and then
i'm saying labels equal to types dot
index
i've used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space and then this is my
format in which i want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution i am going to use shadow so
it says shadow equal to true which is
another parameter
or an argument and then i am going to
start my angle at 60 degrees
and here i have used a title called rule
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally i'm saying plt dot plot
so let me just run it
there you go so here we have a nice
pie chart or a pie plot so you can see
the different pies here
we have all-rounder wicket keeper
batter and bowler
so majorly
there are all-rounders in the auction
followed by bowlers then we have 17.69
percent batters and 10.11 wicket keepers
which is the lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another bar plot
or a bar graph that will tell us how
many players were sold and unsold
so for this i am going to use a count
plot so we'll create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold and
each of the bars will have different
colors
one will have orange the other one will
have pink and i am using
labels so to label the x axis and y axis
i have sold or unsold by label will have
number of players the title of my bar
graph would be sold versus unsold i've
given a font size of 15 and i'm saying
plt.plot
now the function that you see here at
the bottom
will display the data labels for each of
the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so i have used a figure size of 10 comma
5
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now
you can
also print
the total sold and unsold values let me
show you how to do it
i'll say ipl
dot we can use the group by function
and i want to group it by
status column
and
the value that i want to measure is
the player's
count
so i'll say players
rather player and then i'm going to use
the
count function if i run this you can see
here
i've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players are unsold are
396.
cool
now
we are going to see the total number of
players bought by each team
again this is going to be a count plot
so basically a bar plot
so here the condition i'm passing is
in the teams column the value shouldn't
be unsold
so
players bought means the value should be
sold so here i am using this condition
and the rest of the things remains the
same
one improvement i have done here is i am
using x6
rotation equal to 70 degrees this
basically means the x labels would be
tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot there you go so here you
can see i have the title players bought
by each team on the y-axis we have the
number of players
and on the x-axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see better
and this is the bar plot
so the maximum a team can purchase is 25
players some of the teams have also
purchased 24 22 and 23 players let me
just
show you so
gujarat titans have totally purchased 22
players
then
delhi capitals have total 24 players in
their squad
again
lucknow supergiants have 22 players
if i scroll and see again bangalore
loyal challengers or rcb the royal
challenges bangalore have
22 players in the team
and rajasthan royals and sunrises
hyderabad have
24 and 23 players respectively in their
teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns
called
retention
base price
and base price unit for that
first of all i am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to
ipl base price let me just run it
and then
i am going to replace
these values that are present in the
list 2 crore 40 lakh 20 lakh 1 crore 30
lakh 1.5 crore
with
from auction
and i'm saying in place equal to true
let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price
so here
in the base price
column i'm going to replace
draft pick value as 0 so let's run that
as well
and now
i'm going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
bree spice unit and base price so
basically i'm splitting
on the space
that i have let me show you how it is
going to split
so this is let's see our
base price column
what i did was i
replaced the draft pick values to zero
and then the rest of the values will be
split into two columns called base price
unit so basically it will have the
unit
of the base price let's say crores or
lakhs
and the base underscore price column
will have the value which is 2 here 40
20 20 so on so forth
let me just scroll down
and
run that particular cell
now to create
these two columns the base price unit
column and the base underscore price
column i have used the lambda function
and i'm splitting based on the space
let's just run it
now i have replaced
retained with zero
and
let me show you the
final data frame that i have
so here you can see we have replaced
the draft pick values in the base price
column to zero
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that i wanted to
create
so one is called retention
so zeros refer to draft pick
any other value will say
the player was picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores
lacks
and the value base prices 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now
let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so i'll say
ipl let me just scroll down
dot
i'm going to use the
group by function
then i'll say
team
comma
retention
and i am going to
use the value
as
retention because i want to find the
count of
retained players
then i'll say colon
minus 1. let me run it
you can see here
the different team names because i have
grouped by team and then retention so i
have changed super kings
from the auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players
coming to delhi capitals delhi capitals
in the 2022
ipl auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
i scroll down let me talk about let's
say punjab kings they have
pegged 23 players from the auction and
retained two players from
the team last year
talking about
rcb or all challenges bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained
three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here i am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold
and i'm going to use another parameter
called hue for the different colors so
here
i have used hue
as type because i want to
show the players in each team based on
the different types
again i have given my
title to the bar plot
and then i have the x label the y label
and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if i scroll down you can see the
different
types of players here is the legend so
blue is for buller
orange or yellow
it's for all rounder green is for batter
and red
which also looks like maroon is for
wicket keepers
and on the
x axis you can see the different team
names
all right
now let's answer another
couple of questions so here i have
what is the highest amount spent on a
single player by each team
so to solve this question i'll say
my data frame name that is ipl
then i'm going to
say retention
equal to equal to
this should be from auction because you
want to see the highest amount spent and
not
from the retained players
then i'm going to
group
by
i'll say
team
and then
i'll say
cost
in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees that is in crores
and
i'll say
max
colon
-1
dot
sort underscore
values
i'll say ascending
equal to false which means i want the
sorted
result in descending order
okay
let me just
bring this to the left side and we'll
run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it sees
there's a spelling mistake this should
be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
mumbai indians
have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be shan kissin
then
chennai super kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores kolkata knight riders
bought
shreyas a year for 12.25 crores
and so on and so forth
so these are the highest amounts spent
on a single player by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at
maximum value or maximum price
now if you follow ipl
the maximum
price
at which a player was retained happens
to be ravindra jadeja
so let's see at what price was he
retained
i'll say
retention
equal to equal to
i'll say
retained
then i'll say
sort underscore
values
by equal to
i'll use the
same column
cost in
rupees
that's in crores
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot
head
and i want to find the top player
again there's some error
let's see
where is the error
she's ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket i should say
buy
i think this should be
fine now let's run it
there you go
so you can see here our result is player
name ravindra jadeja who was retained
for 16 crores by chennai super kings
cool
now the next cell of code will
display or print the top five bowlers
who have been picked in this year's ipl
based on
their cost in inr
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shraddha thakur
who was bought by
delhi capitals earlier he was part of
csk
for
10.75 crores then we have prasith the
krishna who has been bought by rajasthan
royals this time
last year he was with keker and he has
been bought for 10 crore similarly loki
ferguson has been bought by gujarat
titans
and he played for kkr last season he has
been bought for 10 crores while his base
price was too close then we have avish
khan
you can see avishkhan's base price was
just 20 lakhs and he has been bought for
10 crores by lucknow super giants again
and last year he was part of the daily
capitals
now you can replace
this value
suppose let's say you want to find the
top five batsman's picked or batters
picked with the highest amount you can
just see
batter instead of bowler and if i run
this
you can see here
surya's ayer was bought by
kolkata nitriders for 12.25 crores last
year he was part of delhi capitals
then you have
shimran hitmaya who's from
west indies he has been
picked by the rajasthan royals for
five crores then we have rahul tribati
sikha dhaban and that particle
now if you wanted to check for
let's say all rounders
you can replace batter with all rounder
if i run this
you can see
lamb living stone has been bought by
punjab kings this season
for
11.5 crores his beast price was just one
crore and last year he was part of the
rajasthan royals
then we have a player from sri lanka
asaranga then we have hershel patel
shahrukh khan and rahul devatia who have
been
the top five all-rounders picked at
highest amount
cool
now finally
we want to
see the players who were part of the ipl
last season but were not picked for this
year's ipl
so for that what i'm doing is first i'm
renaming my
2021 squad column
this column i want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
i am going to find out the unsold
players so here i am saying previous
team not equal to
not participated
and then
i am using another condition team should
be equal to equal to unsold and i'm
going to find out only the player and
the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the ipl last
season but
they haven't been picked this season and
last season they had played for let's
say suresh reiner played for csk steve
smith was part of the delhi capitals
sakib hassan
was part of kkr if i scroll down you
have david milan who played for punjab
kings in 2021
oin morgan
who played for kkr he also captained kkr
but unfortunately he was
not picked this season chris lane from
australia also
remained unsold this season
and to thai we have been cutting aditya
there are other players as well
we have kane richardson dhawal kulkarni
cool so these were the players who are
part of the ipl season 2021 but
unfortunately were not picked and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on
ipl data analysis 2022 so we learned
how to
use the different functions
and attributes that are part of
the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualized the data and
answered some specific questions
formula one also known as f1 is a
motorsport defined by open wheeled
single seat race cars
it features the best drivers in the most
powerful and technically advanced cars
the sport is governed by the fia that is
international automobile federation
here 10 teams comprising of two drivers
each compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and constructor champion
in our demonstration we'll be using four
data sets let me show them one by one
these are all csv files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo
so if you notice the data set does not
have columns
names in fact none of the data sets have
column names so while importing the data
set we'll assign the column names using
the names parameter
i'll show that in a
while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
the result id
then we have the race id driver id
we have
the constructor id
grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest
lap then we also have information about
rank
the fastest lap speed
and the status id
now moving on to the second data set
which is about
races
now this is the second data set which is
about races so
it has information about the race id
the year in which the race was held then
we have
the round number circuit id
then the name of the grand prix so you
can see here australia and malaysia and
chinese spanish monaco turkish british
german
and others
then we have the
date on which the gp was held or the
gone pre was
held
we have the time
and a url which basically leads to the
wikipedia page of that particular
grand prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set so
this is our third data set which is
about
drivers
now it has the driver id the name of the
driver you can see here hamilton
rossberg alonso
ryken
then we have sato
masa
button weber and all
after that we have the
number code
then we have the
phone name of the driver the surname of
the driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well
we have the wikipedia page
for the
driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
constructors
so this is the fourth and the final data
set that we'll be using in our data
analysis project
so here we have the constructor id
then the constructor reference
in formula one
and this is the actual name of the
constructor so we have mclaren
we have
bmw sauber williams then we have ferrari
toyota red bull force india
we also have jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the url
that is the wikipedia page of
that particular constructor
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my jupyter notebook that i'll be
using for this demo you can see some of
the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we
save some time
so using these data sets that we just
saw and our libraries such as numpy
pandas matplotlib and cbon
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and constructors who have
been the most successful throughout the
history of f1 sport
then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and if
the speed of the cars has changed over
the years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here i am importing numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbon
and after that i am writing percentage
matplotlib inline
that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line i'll
hit shift enter to run it
take some time there you go so we have
successfully imported all the libraries
now the next step is to
load the data and assign
column names
so
i'll load my
first data which is results i'll say pd
dot
read underscore
csv
i'll give my
file name which is results dot
csv
and then using the
names parameter
i'll pass in the
column names so actually i have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so i have this f1
notepad created which has the column
names i'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter i'll paste it
if i scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that
have been assigned
and
that
i'm going to say
comma
and i'll write
header equal to none
i'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's
import the second data set which is
about
races i'll say
pd dot
read underscore csv
i'll give my
file name which is racist.csv
and then
i'll give the
names parameter this is actually names
and not name
okay
i'm going to
copy the
second line
and i'll paste it here
and again
i'll say
header
equal to
none
next
we'll import our third data set which is
about
drivers
so i'll say pd dot read underscore csv
i'll say
drivos.csv
then
again use the
names parameter
and i'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names
for the
drivers data set
here
i
need to give
another parameter which is
header
equal to
none
finally we are going to import our
constructors data set
it's a constructors equal to pd dot
read underscore csv which is the
function present in the pandas library
i'll say
constructors dot csv which is my
file name
and then again i'll use the names
parameter
i'll go to my notepad and this time i'll
copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors data set
i'll paste it
and
here i'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right
now
let me hit shift enter to
run it
okay we see some error here let's debug
the error it says
no such file or directory drivers dot
csv
let's see
where was the issue
this should be
driver.csv
cool now we have successfully loaded the
data and assigned the columns to the
various datasets
now the
next
analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here i'll create a data frame called
df and i'll use
pd dot
merge function
first i'll use the
results data frame that we just
imported above
this one
and
i'm going to merge it with
racis data frame
and from the resist data frame i am
going to take
specific columns like the
race id
then
i need the
year
after that i need
name
next
i'm going to take
the round column as well
and
i'm going to use
on parameter so
on parameter
is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and recess
so here my common column
is going to be the race id because it is
present in both the data sets
and i would like to merge
so for that i'm going to use how so i'm
going to use a left join
so
if you know sql you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table and only the matching rows
from the right table
again going to use the merge function so
i'll write
df equal to pd dot
merge
i'll say df comma and now i'm going to
merge the
ivor's data set
and
i'm going to select specific columns so
i'll say
driver id
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
in the
column names
then i'll say
driver
ref which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma
and then i want the
nationality of the driver
all right
we'll give a comma i'll say on
which column i want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver id
again
how is going to be a left join
into the final
merge part i'll say again df equal to pd
dot merge
i'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which i have is about
constructors
from constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so i'll take the
constructor
id
then
i'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
here i'll say
on
equal to
the common column i'll use is
constructor id
give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
cool
make sure
you're merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the four data sets
i'll hit
enter
oops there is some error let's see it
says constructor
id index
okay there's a spelling mistake this
should be
constructor id cool
let's run it
there you go
now
the next thing we want to do is to drop
the unnecessary columns
so i'll say df dot
drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names i'll say
number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have
position underscore
text
after that we have
labs
next we are going to drop
fastest
lap
then we will also drop the
status id
comma
we'll drop the
result underscore id column
then
going to drop the race underscore id
column
we'll also drop
driver underscore id column
and finally we are going to drop
the
constructor underscore id column
and
i'll say access equal to
1
and in place i'll c equal to true
because i want to remove it from my
original data frame that is df
there you go
now the next
thing i want to do is i want to rename
some of the columns so i'll say df dot
rename
i'll say
columns equal to
now we are going to pass in a dictionary
i'm going to change the
rank
to
test
underscore lab underscore rank
let me give a comma
now i'll say
name underscore x
equal to
i'll say the
grand prix name so i'll say gp
underscore name
next column i'm going to focus is
the nationality column so i'll say
nationality underscore
x
i'll give a colon the value i'm going to
pass in is
driver nationality
all right
up next
we have one column called
underscore
y
and that i'm going to change it to
constructor name
another comma
i'm going to say
nationality
underscore
y
colon
change it to
constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column
and that i'm going to replace with
just
driver
finally i'll say
in place
equal to
true
well
just verify if all the column names are
correct
let's run it
all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell i am going to rearrange
the columns so here i am
using the same data frame and we have
just renamed the columns so starting
with your
grand prix name round driver
nationality
and others
let's run this
up next
we are going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete
so i'll say df equal to
df
then i'll say
here
not
equal to
2090
let's see how to
sort the values so i'll say df equal to
df dot sort underscore values which is
the function name
i am going to sort it by
here
followed by
round
followed by
the
position
underscore
order comma i'll say
ascending
equal to
first let's say is false
next i have true
and then
i'll have true
all right
moving ahead
now we are going to see how to replace
the
put slash
n values in
the time column with
something called nan because the time
column was not registered when a driver
did not finish a race or was lagged by
another driver
so to do this i am going to say
df dot
time
dot i'm going to use the replace
function
and here i'll say
forward slash
or backward slash
n
and i'm going to replace with
numpy's nan
i'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
emitters
next i'm going to replace the
milliseconds value
milliseconds dot
replace i'll paste it here
then i'll say df dot
fastest
underscore lab underscore
rank dot
replace
paste it
next i have
df dot
fastest dot
lap
dot
time
they replace
to that i have
the next column which is
speed so i'll say fastest
underscore
lap underscore
speed dot replace
i'll paste it
so here
i'm going to replace
this particular value
the
backward slash n with
nan
let me run it
cool
step i'm going to
change the data types for
fastest underscore lab underscore speed
to float then fastest underscore lab
underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float
again for milliseconds also we are
changing it to float values
let me run it
now
i'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
i'll say df dot
reset
underscore
index
i'll say
drop
equal to
true
give a comma and say
in place equal to true
all right
that we have
done our initial
processing step of the data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see all the data sets the
total number of non-null values the
memory usage and we'll
check the head of the data set
now to see the total number of
rows and columns i'll say print
df dot shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use df dot
info function
so it gives me the
year the grand prix name
the round number
driver constructor name grid
position order total number of points
time
then time in milliseconds the fastest
lap rank
the fastest lap speed
the nationality of the driver
nationality of the constructor then here
we have the
total number of non-null objects
and then you also have the memory usage
at the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so i'll see df
dot
head let's say i want to check the first
10 rows
where you go
if i scroll down you can see here we
have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the year the grand prix
name round driver constructor name and
other columns now let me just
brief you about what these column names
stand for
so the year column that you see here is
this season that the grand prix took
place and then we have the
name of the grand prix
now the round column is the number of
the race in each season for example one
means it was the first race of the
season
and then two means it was the second
race of the season so so on and so forth
then we have the name of the driver
for that we have the
name of the car constructor so you can
see ferrari mercedes red bull renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race
then we have the points column that is
the total number of points scored in the
race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the winner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if i just scroll down
i'll just move to the
right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lap
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during a race next we have
fastest lap time that is the shortest
amount of time that took to complete a
lap in the release
then we have the lap speed that is the
average speed of the
fastest lap then we have the
country to which the driver belongs to
and then we have the
constructor nationality that is the
country where the car constructor is
based out of
okay
now here i'm going to
set my figure size to 10 comma 6 this is
going to be for all the
plots that we are going to create
afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the grand prix winners
so here i'm going to say
driver
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame
df dot i'll say loc
then i'll say
df
i want
the position underscore
order
and that should be equal to 1 so which
means
the driver
1 degrees
and then
i'm going to use the
group by function
i'm going to group it by
driver
and
values i'll see
position underscore
order
use the
count function
followed by
sort underscore
values
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
change it to
to underscore
frame
dot
reset
underscore
index
what essentially i am doing here is i am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and
won a grand prix
next
i am going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so i'll say
sb
which we have taken in our
analysis ideally it should be sns but sb
also will work
so i'll say sb
dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
driver underscore
winner
the y-axis i'll have
driver
in the x-axis i'll have
position
underscore
order
then i have
color equal to
green
that i'll set my
alpha value
to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so i'll say plt
dot
title
let's say most
grand prix
winners in f1
then we are going to label our access so
for y label i will have
driver
name
we have
the x label
that will have
number of
grand prix wins
and i'll
say plt dot
y
text
cool
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot
shows that there are
a large distribution of
grand prix events
only a few drivers in history of f1 have
won over 20 grand prairie in their
careers and there are some drivers who
completely dominated the f1 racing and
have won over
50 grand priest in their careers so we
are going to focus on those
top five or top 10
drivers
in the next section so what i'm doing
here is
from the
above
result that we just got i'm going to
filter out only the
top 10 so i'm going to use the head
function
and inside that i passed in 10 if i
print it
you can see here
as per the data that we have
we have michael schumacher who
is the
position order leader with 91 gp events
then we have hamilton vettel prost sena
alonso
then we have stevert clerk and lauda
the data that we have is
not the most recent one so if you check
the actual stats hamilton has actually
overtaken michael sumacher and has
won over
103 close to 103 races as of now
and next we have michael somacker so
this is not the most recent data
cool
now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so i'll say sb dot
bar plot
i'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so i'll say top 10
drivers
in the y axis we'll have
the
driver name
in the x-axis will have
position
underscore
order
for the bars i'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
i'll set my alpha value
to be
0.8
and
i'll say let's say
line
width
equal to
0.8
and i'll also give
an edge color of let's say
black
follow the same drill i'm going to give
a title to my plot so i'll say plt dot
title
most
gp
winners in a phone
will give a y label
that says
driver
name
and then i'll have
x label which will have
number of
on pre
bins
cool let me see if everything is fine
and then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal
bar plot that shows the
top drivers in f1 so as per our data
that we have we have michael schumacher
who has won over 91 or close to
91
races then we have hamilton vettel
alonso clark and others
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top constructors that
have participated in f1
so here i'm finding out
all the
constructor winners so here
i'm using my position underscore order
equal to equal to 1 and then i'm using
the group by
based on the constructor name
and then i'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values
in
descending order and i'm changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot i'm using the
bar plot function the data which is
constructor underscore winner
in the y-axis i'll have the constructor
name on the x-axis i'll have the
position order
so you can see here i've used color as
pink and i've given a title x-label by
label
and bytex
let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely
spread
so we have a lot of constructor names
now
our next task is to
check the
top 10 gpa constructor windows so here
i'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10 if i run it
you can see here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of races
are ferrari mclaren williams then we
have mercedes red bull tim lotus renault
and others
okay
now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10
constructors
now let me show you how to do it
so i'll say
sb which is for c bond dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 constructors
scroll down i'll say constructors
y-axis i'll have
constructor
on the x axis i'll have
position underscore order
then
i'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars
then i'll set my
alpha to
0.8
i'll say
line width equal to
0.8
and my
edge
color i'll say
black
that i'll say plt dot
title
say top 10
most
gp
wins
lt dot
by label would be
constructor
name
and i'll have plt dot
x label
as
number of
gp
bins
cool
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
ferrari at the top then we have mclaren
williams more cities i'm pretty certain
by
the end of 2021 season mercedes would
have gained a lot of wins
since hamilton
has been on the top
for mercedes for quite some time now
all right
now
finally we are going to
create a
regression plot that will
show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing position
vary
so to do that i am going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the
pit lane
so
i'm using this function called reg plot
to plot my
regression line
let me run it and show you the result
there you go
so if you see here
we can easily see there is a linear
relationship between the starting and
finishing position so on the x axis we
have the starting position on the y axis
we have the
finishing or the finish place so which
is what is actually expected right
now we can also see that
most races had up to
25 drivers you can see the density of
the points here
but
some of the recess also had over 30
drivers you can see the
light color blue dots
next
we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years since this data
is only available from 2004 onwards so
we have
we have taken
years that start from 2004 onwards
now let me show you the result
of this data
so essentially we are plotting the
average speed among
all teams during the fastest lap at
individual grand prix and here on the
y axis you have the average fastest
speed in kilometer per hour and then you
have the different
gps
and
you can see here the year values
now
in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around
2050
for almost all the circuits
and again from 2015 onward the speed
started
to increase
you can see here there's an increase
after 2015 there's an increase there's
an increase here as well
you can also notice that
the speed is very different on each
track for instance if you check the
italian grand prix which is
here italian gp has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over
240 kilometers per hour
on the other hand if you
talk about the
monaco grand prix let me show you if you
see here
the monaco gp is the slowest race with
average speed below
160 kilometer per hour now this is
actually expected because the monaco
grand prix
has very narrow streets and
hence the drivers cannot
drive fast in this circuit
all right
so
so now we are going to look at
healthcare market forecast
so as per
markets and markets.com
the healthcare analytics market is
projected to reach 75.1 billion us
dollars by 2026 from 21.1 billion us
dollars in 2021.
now talking about
india
statista.com india's healthcare sector
was about 160 billion u.s dollars in
2017
it was estimated to reach up to 372
billion us dollars by 2022.
as per rbc capital markets approximately
30 percent of the world's data is
generated by the healthcare industry
by 2025 the compound annual growth rate
of data in healthcare will reach 36
percent now that is six percent faster
than manufacturing 10 faster than
financial services and 11 faster than
media and entertainment
now let's see the various applications
and issues that analytics can solve in
healthcare
we will look at drug discovery staffing
and operation
and see how analytics can help predict
diseases
so talking about
drug discovery
now the drug discovery is a very long
process sometimes it takes about 12
years and costs way too much about 2.6
billion us dollars
now data analytics can increase the drug
delivery process rate in medical science
helping to gain faster approval from the
food and drug administration
it can help optimize and improve the
efficiency of clinical trials
another key development that has
happened in a number of pharmaceutical
companies like astrazeneca bayer
cleansing
and jensen research and development has
recently announced a data sharing
initiative called project data sphere
these companies have agreed to share
historical cancer research data to help
researchers in the fight against the
disease today
the database will be available online
globally and the analytics technology
would be provided by software vendor sas
now moving on
we have
staffing and operation
now this is another crucial problem that
every staff manager in hospital faces
that is the problem of staff allocations
at a given period
understanding how many people a manager
should put on a staff at any given time
period can be very challenging
if you put too many workers the risk of
having unnecessary labor costs go up
too few workers you can have poor
customer service outcomes
which can be fatal for patients
so business analysts can use data to
forecast patient admission trends at
specific times of the day and provide
insights to the staff managers to assign
the right number of staff during peak
and slow periods
next we'll talk about
predicting diseases
so business analytics can also predict
trends in the spread of illness allowing
doctors hospitals medical staff and
individuals to adequately prepare
themselves
for example in the case of coronavirus
analyzing data to predict future spikes
in cases can help hospitals ensure the
staff have enough protective equipment
and patient beds
using medical imaging and algorithms
physicians can detect diabetic
retinopathy which is a condition that
damages the eye due to diabetes and
algorithms can also help detect cancer
cells in a patient
detecting cancer at an early stage has
been a focused area in healthcare for
quite some time now
the cancer moonshot initiative by former
u.s president barack obama initiated in
his second term relies on advanced
analytical techniques to pace up the
discovery of cancer cures by identifying
the trends and treatments used worldwide
that have the highest success rate
now
let's look at the hand washing case
study in detail
so to give you some context before the
mid 19th century
the science of bacteria was not
discovered yet
nobody knew that microorganisms could
spread diseases back then even hospital
staff did not follow basic hygiene
practices
not even doctors cared to wash their
hands now to be honest we all realized
the importance of hand washing after the
world was hit by coronavirus pandemic
now meet
dr
ignaz simelweis
he was a hungarian-born doctor and
practiced at the vienna general
hospital's maternity clinic between 1846
and 1849
dr simelweis is regarded as the father
of infection control for discovering the
medical benefits of hand washing
dr simelweis was very disturbed by the
increasing fatality rate of mothers from
childbed fever at vienna hospital so
child bed fever is also known as
pure peril fever
it happens due to infections in the
female reproductive tract following
childbirth
this child fever was an issue of concern
throughout europe with some hospitals
having over 40 percent mortality rate so
out of every 100 mothers who used to
give birth at least 40 mothers would die
in a week or two weeks time
so the demo case study i am going to
present now concerns the work of dr
ignac's symbol wise in reducing the risk
of childbirth fever during childbirth in
vienna hospital during the mid 19th
century so he collected and analyzed
historical data on debts in his clinic
and established a theory
of what was contributing to increasing
deaths of mothers
now to solve a problem business analysts
would often need to collect data from
multiple sources for this demo we'll be
using three data sets that are publicly
accessible on kegel and github let me
go ahead and show you the three data
sets first
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
okay so this is the first data set that
i have which is called the yearly fever
mortality data set so here you can see
the first column is about year it starts
from
1784
and it goes till
1846
the next column we have is about the
total number of births that took place
at the vienna general hospital maternity
clinic and then we have the total number
of deaths reported from child bed fever
next
then we have the
fever mortality per clinic so
in the vienna hospital
there were two separate clinics that
operated between
1833 and 1846
birth one
column represents the total number of
births that took place
in clinic one
similarly
that's one column represents the total
number of deaths that took place in
clinic one of the
maternity clinic at vienna general
hospital births two and that's two
has the information about the births and
deaths that happened in clinic two
then we have the
final data set
this data set is about
monthly debts which starts from
january
1841
till
march
1849
we have the total number of births and
the total number of deaths and this
monthly underscored deaths is only for
clinic one
we'll learn in detail about clinic one
and clinic 2 at the maternity hospital
and what they represent in detail
all right
ok
so
this is my jupyter notebook which has
the
lines of code already written i'm going
to
explain you each cell of code and we'll
explore
the hand washing case study by looking
at the outputs for each of the cells
let's start with the first cell so here
i'm going to import my first data set
which is the
yearly fever
mortality
this is a csv data set
and to
load the data set i'm using the pandas
library and the read underscore csp
function
i'm using
parse underscore
dates equal to
year so this
parse underscore dates will format the
year column in the form of a date value
next
i have
set
my index to be the year column you can
see here set underscore index equal to
year and i am mentioning that in place
equal to true which means that the
original data is now modified and
updated in place
and i'm importing the data
and storing it in a variable called
yearly underscore that's
next i'm going to print my
data set
let me just
hit shift enter
we can see the result
there is an error here it says
okay this should be yearly underscore
deaths
let me run it again
there you go
so here you can see we have set the year
column as our index
you can see the year column is our index
then we have the
other two columns the total number of
births and the total number of deaths
starting from
1784
till
1846
all right
now
you can see
the values for year total births and the
total number of deaths from 1784 till
1846 in the maternity clinic of vienna
hospital where similvoice used to
practice
coming to the
next cell of code
here
we are going to calculate the
mortality rate or the mortality
percentage for that i'm going to create
a new column called as
mortality
so here i'm mentioning my data frame
which is yearly underscore deaths that
we created above and then within square
brackets i am passing in
my new column name which is mortality
and the
formula to calculate mortality is
total
deaths
divided by
the total number of births into hundred
now let's print the result
you can see here we have added a new
column called mortality and it has given
us the
mortality rate
for each of the years starting from 1784
till 1846
now next
we are
going to find out some descriptive
statistics using the describe function
so i've used yearly underscore deaths
dot describe
if i run it you can see the
count that is the total number of rows
that are there in our
data set
then we have the
mean birth so the
average birth
that has taken place in all these years
per year is around 2268.
the total debts reported in each of the
years that is the average number of
debts is around 93 and the mortality is
around three percent or 3.3 percent we
have the standard deviation
we have the
minimum value that is the
least births that took place in one of
the years was
284 and the maximum is 4010
then we have the 25th percentile the
50th percentile and the 75th percentile
we are going to create our first plot
that is
taught about yearly mortality rate each
year between
1784 till 1846
now here we are going to create a line
plot and for that
i'm going to import my matplotlib dot pi
plot as plt
i'm setting my figure size to be 14
comma 5
and using the plot function i am going
to create my line plot
i have given my
data value as mortality rate
i am going to use
color as green and marker as
so o will represent as dots and after
that i am going to give a title as
mortality from childbirth fever during
childbirth i have given a x label as
year and y label as mortality rate
let's run and see the output
there you go
if i scroll down
you can see here we have a nice
line chart
now we can notice that the modality rate
started increasing somewhere around
1823 from here you can see a spike
and gradually the
mortality rate or fatality rate from
child bed fever started increasing from
around 1820
the reason was you can see here there
was a sharp increase after
1823
so the reason
was
around 1823
civil wise clinic started giving lessons
on
pathological anatomy
so
pathology i guess you would know is the
branch of medicine that deals with the
study of
causes and effects of diseases
so doctors would take classes on the
corpses organs and tissues to learn the
reasons for the cause of the death
so after the post mortems then they
might deliver a baby or examine a
patient
possibly with pieces of contaminated
flesh remaining in their hands
so similar wise suspected that this
could be the reason for childbed fever
he continued with his analysis and
looked for further evidence to support
his hypothesis
not till
1832 there was only one maternity clinic
at the vienna hospital
now that had become very overcrowded so
an extension was built and two clinics
were created in
1833 you can see it here
now until
1840 both clinics were used for teaching
and training medical students and
midwives
so midwives are people who help mothers
deliver babies and take care of newborns
after childbirth
so after 1840 the physicians
that included doctors and medical
students used to operate in clinic one
and only midwives used to operate in
clinic two after eighteen forty
so similwise spotted that in clinic one
the fatality rate for mothers from
childbed fever was three times more than
those who delivered in clinic two
so you can see here in clinic one which
was the doctor's word
and for people
who
were given trainings the mortality rate
was ten percent while in clinic two
where only the midwives operated the
mortality rate was three percent
so he again believed that in clinic one
where doctors and physicians operated
they also used to handle corpses during
autopsies before operating on pregnant
women
and they never used to wash their hands
between the two jobs
but midwives in clinic 2 never went to
the autopsy room so similarwise spotted
that there were links between the lack
of hygiene of the doctors and the
mortality rate of the mothers
so let's analyze that data now
cool
so i'm going to import my second data
set which has the information about
births and deaths in clinic one and
clinic two so here i'm importing my csv
data set and i'm storing it
in a data frame name called clinics
again i've used
parse underscore dates as year to format
the
date values i've given my
file location followed by the
file name
and dot the extension of the file which
is csv file
again i have set my index to be the year
column
and i'm printing the head of the data
frame now let me hit shift enter
okay so here you can see
1833
onwards birth one death one that is for
clinic one then we have both two that's
two for clinic two
next
we are going to calculate the mortality
for both the clinics that is clinic one
and clinic two so what i am doing here
is i am creating
two columns mortality one and mortality
two so mortality one is for clinic one
then mortality two is for clinic two
again the formula is the same deaths
divided by births into 100 is the
mortality rate
let me run it
and now we are going to see the
first 10 rows from our newly created
data frame you can see here we have
added two more columns mortality one and
mortality two
and these are the results
now if you notice
see the mortality rate
for the clinic one where
dr semelweis used to practice
or the physicians who also operated on
the
dead bodies
used to practice so the mortality rate
is high
there
now let's
compare
and visualize the mortality rate
at both the clinics so here i'm again
setting my figure size to be 14 comma 5
i've used
clinics
dot index mortality one i've given a
label as clinic one
color i'm using as steel marker is
o
so this o will make sure for each of the
years we have a
dot or
a round shape
similarly for clinic two we have
mortality two i'm using
blue color again marker as o
then i'm giving a legend
a title called mortality from childbed
fever during childbirth i also have a
while label called mortality rate
let's run it
now if i scroll down you can see
the mortality rate
from
1833 onwards till 1846 for both the
clinics
the teal color represents clinic one and
the blue color represents clinic two
so from this graph we can see that the
death rate at clinic 1 was significantly
higher after
1840 you can see there has
a huge spike
compared to clinic 2 where only the
midwives practiced and they never
operated on the dead bodies in the
autopsy room
so now doctor simul vice had strong
evidence to believe that the doctors
were transmitting infectious flesh or
you can say material substances from
previous operations to mothers through
their hands and this was leading to
childbirth fever
so far
we have seen in our analysis till
eighteen hundred and forty six
and dr semelweis in mid
1847 asked his colleagues and fellow
physicians at maternity clinic one to
wash their hands with chlorinated lyme
solution before attending pregnant
mothers and the results were significant
so let's see the final analysis of
clinic one where doctor simulates
practiced and how he was able to reduce
the mortality rate
now i'm going to load the monthly
deaths data set that has information
from january 1841 till march 1849
and after 1849 his contract was
terminated and he was asked to leave the
vienna hospital i'll tell you why he was
asked to leave
a little later
let's load the final data set now
okay so
i'm going to import my final data set
which is the monthly underscore debts
dot csv i am storing it
in a variable called monthly underscore
data let me run it
so here you can see
the
data for
all the months starting from
january 1841 till march 1849
next
i'm going to find the monthly
mortality at clinic one
so
i'm going to divide the debts divided by
births into 100
so here you can see we have created new
column called proportional underscore
debts
that has the
death rate for each of the months
now the doctors in clinic one started
washing their hands in june
1847 before carrying out delivery
operations
so
we have divided
the original data into two data frames
called
before washing and
then we have after washing
we will set the start of hand washing
date to
1st of june 1847
you can see here i have said
start of hand washing pandas dot 2 data
frame i am giving my
hand washing start date that is 1st of
june
1847. or washing data frame will have
all the values that lie prior to june
1847 so here i have subset my data i'm
saying
date should be less than
a date which is first of june
1847 and after washing should be
greater than equal to first of june
1847.
you run this
i'll print my before
washing data frame you can see
it has taken all the values till
may 1847
and for after washing we have all the
values starting from june 1847 till
we have
march 1849
so we have split
months data into before and after hand
washing start date
now let's
plot our final
graph that shows the difference in the
modality rate of mothers
before and after hand washing
so here
i am setting ax which is the axis
before washing
dot plot will create a line plot i am
saying x to be date y to be proportional
deaths i'm giving my label to be before
hand washing i'm using color
as c which is for c n
then here b represents blue
this is for after hand washing again x
should be date y should be proportional
underscore deaths
here i'm using a line style to be dotted
lines to just
you know compare the plots
i've set my while label to be proportion
depth let's run it
and you can see the
result
let me scroll down
there you go on the x-axis we have the
date on the y-axis we have the
proportion depth
the
cn color represents before hand washing
that is the solid line and we have the
dotted lines for
after hand washing
now you can see how
starting from the summer of
1847
the proportion of deaths got reduced
significantly less than five percent you
can see here
so this was when civil wise made hand
washing
mandatory
now
we'll calculate the difference in
average monthly percentage debts before
and after hand washing so what i'm doing
is i'm creating
two variables before proportion and
after proportion
then we are going to subtract
before proportion mean minus the after
proportion mean if you see the
difference you can see here it is eight
point three percent so from
ten percent we just
reduced it to less than three percent
so this was all about the
hand washing case study that simulvise
had conducted using different data sets
so we perform this explorative data
analysis using three data sets
and you explored how using pandas and
matplotlib you can create
different charts and analyze data
yearly data
or time series data
the sad part is that with all this
exploratory analysis and the findings dr
simelweis made his superiors at vena
hospital refused to
accept his theory and he was met with a
lot of criticism
medical community rejected his discovery
in march 1849 and he was forced to leave
the vienna general hospital
one reason we can argue as business
analyst is that
statistical analysis and data
visualization were very uncommon those
days in the field of medical science
simulwise only published his data as
long tables of raw data but he couldn't
show any graphs or confidence intervals
to support his hypothesis
his ideas were considered as offense to
the medical community he hurt them
since similar wise meant that doctors
were the cause of increased deaths he
believed in another theory called
meismus which basically means some bad
component in the air was the cause of
childbed fever deaths
after
two decades
when
joseph lister and luis pasture produced
more evidence of the germ theory and
antiseptic techniques only then the
value of hand washing was appreciated
but nevertheless his work was based on
evidence supported by numbers showing
that simple hand washing by health care
workers could save millions of lives
later he did get some recognition
the budapest university where doctor
ignace semelweis used to teach
after getting terminated from vienna
general hospital is now named as
simulvice university
in january 2019
the statue of dr
simelweis was unveiled at the world
health organization by the current
director general mr trados you can see
on the right on the left we have the
state secretary of the ministry of
foreign affairs and trade
from hungary
on the 100th anniversary of his death
the government of austria issued a
postage stamp in his honor
and in march 2020 after the world was
hit by coronavirus google also
recognized symbolwice hand washing
findings and gave him a will doodle
the best way to master a language is by
programming in it if you enjoy watching
such tech videos make sure to subscribe
to our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update
so what's in store for you
we'll first create some simple beginner
level projects like how to build a
calculator app
then we'll move on to more advanced apps
like the weather app
the tic tac toe game
and finally we'll conclude the session
by creating a snake game application
now i'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin so we have
decided to basically develop very
interesting project in javascript that
is known as calculator application
like you've seen earlier some projects
like in tic-tac-toe you talk about snake
game you talk about quiz application
this time we're going to introduce you
another very interesting project using
this javascript html css
so so-called calculator application so
let's get started let me try to delete
first those files which we really do not
need it now
uh
we delete this all
yeah now i'll be creating a new folder
now include the name called
calculator
and in this calculator app once again we
need some new files which is called
index
dot html
and we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is called app dot
js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html5 where we'll be creating a
template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a good body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator
so that will be my h1 heading
after that we will start working with
the div tag
now within this div
i have to create many classes i may not
have lot many css classes but we can
give some classes here so we can say
class equal to
container
okay so within this div tag we're going
to create a table now because i want to
organize it
so starting with the table within this
table
tr tag
and within this tr tag i need a td
now in this td i need few things call
call
span
equal to 3
another value
and here
i want to offer the text box
input type equal to
text
okay input text id equal to give the
name called result
that will be the final outcome while uh
pressing all the different buttons id go
to result and
class
equal to
screen remember i haven't created those
css classes but but we're giving some
names but later on we can utilize it
while creating those css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now insert this td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here in this input text sorry i would
like to better say button because i'll
be having
buttons
okay
input f equal to
button
value
equal to
c
and
one click
equal to i may not have any function
right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some domain
name here
i'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function will
get called
and after that class
equal to
clear
yeah so this is my button tag
after this our td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another table row
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here
and inside this td i'll be having
another button we get created
so i'll just say
this is another button now input equal
to button value equal to
one on click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call 1
okay and class equal to member
equal to
number
and here after that tag is getting
closed
okay now we have to start another td tag
here
okay like that we have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 contributor
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what
number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like
now i can see the buttons like in c123
but yes i'm going to create few more
buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here
and create few more buttons so this is
where the table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this and paste it again
i have to create
the button
like in
3 4 something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
i'll give the value call 3
so val equal to 2 value equal to 3
display 3
and then afterwards
just giving the value called
forward slash
and here also we're going gonna keep the
value called
forward slash
and here class is equal to
operator
operator
after that
you have to do the value call 4
and then followed by five six seven
so here we give four
four
five
five
six
six
after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about call seven
then we have to have eight
okay nine
okay after that we're giving call plus
and
display
plus plus equal to operator
operator okay so here
you can see the table data is getting
closed and here the table is also
getting closed and after this table row
you can start working with
another table row here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
okay
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is value equal to
dot and here we get the value called
decimal
decision
okay
now display 0
so after giving this dot to basically
take what the value
zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have the other one
zero
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that we'll be once again
taking this
this time rather than giving this zero
we'll be using this call as a button
and value equal to equal
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this soft will not be
passing anything
it like a normal function
and plus equal to
equal
okay so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we will be using
val equal to
multiplication
display
plastic and here we'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table is
getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your div tag is also getting
closed here
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome
so we have got
all those
necessary calculator behavior
which
we wanted to
reveal
okay now our next statement will be once
we're giving this c then we have to call
one two three
and then forward slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so let me check whether we have
used six or not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five
six so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later
before
minus
6 equal to
okay so we're almost set now so we are
having this uh
look and feel
in this we are giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then plus related behavior so we are all
set now and after that we'll be
basically applying the css as well as
the javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
uh this outlook is looking properly or
not see what my expectation is after one
two three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next
and then seven eight nine and again
forward but i can think this is
absolutely unorganized
so after this when we say
this forward slash which we have used
after harison
okay your td is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start another tr here
okay so that i can put them into the
another level now so under this tr i can
use this td now so after this minus
after four five six
minus once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
okay
starting another tier after that we talk
about seven eight nine
okay plus
see here talking about seven eight nine
plus here the table is getting close and
it is starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which i
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it later on
okay because you can see eight is
missing right now
so here
seven
we copy this
equal to eight
eight
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized
so the moment i expect my application
so we have a call
dot here then zero then equal to and
then
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel
so i need to go ahead and use what css
because without css i really can't
utilize this in a proper way so i have
to start working with the css friend now
in css front how to start first we will
go back to my code and here in my css
we'll start working with
font family but before font fabric i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using called t
that looks nice
okay
so
i will be using this app.css
in my html to see the look how it has
been appeared right now so in my
index.html file on the top under my head
section
link
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css we want to use
some h1 correct tool so here
we would like to use the h1
text align
sector
color
white
margin top
margin top would like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement will be called a screen
so we say towards
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
diagram color gray
and after that border
sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
we're using this
100
then we talk about cursor
what are the default cursor is
okay then padding
you would like to say 10 pixels
and then
margin
save auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want that's for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me
and rest of the details we'll be showing
you one by one and now we'll be talking
about call input
input
type
equal to button
for input type equal to
button
background color change to what
right or else i can say
let's walk
okay
and
when the button is active what i want
let me copy
and put a little button and here i say
active
and this color should be orange red
like this
you can see now how it is basically
looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about operators
operator should behave different so i'm
saying dot
operator
in this operator we are saying
background color
background color orange
okay that padding
i want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using call border
sorry
that border
i'm using this called solid
and then black
after this bit
i'm using hundred percent
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursive
it has to be pointed
okay that's it let's check
perfect so they should turn back to what
your
then i need height
of type 40 pixels
then i say color
it looks i want to say called black
then border
border we want solid
black into excess solid
black
for decimal i need to have a different
options with me
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it and i say for
does it
so for decimal background color will be
light blue
padding 5 pixels color black border
solid
okay black 2 pixels hundred percent
height forty pixels fine cursor
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light
now
i talk about
clear
okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color
background color is changed to light
salmon
line segment
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width 100
height 40 pixels
fine so cursor
pointer
file margin
auto and margin bottom
merging bottom differences
let's check
perfect not looks beautiful
okay
now
here
after giving these details we're talking
about call equal part dot equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so we recall
background color padding color
just change to
lightly
lightly
and
after this
since it is equal so we say padding five
pixels is okay color black fine border
fine with hundred percent height forty
pixels
color and cursor pointers just i don't
need to
it's for dot equal and i want
for container
container
in this container width i want 40
percent
white
okay
now
here
padding is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all width
you see
display block
which we're taking margin
okay in merchandising to pixels
auto
okay now align cells
go to
center
okay border radius
border radius let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
box shadow 5 pixels
black
and body
so these are details
okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell display block border radius
padding
then you know
writing 15 pixels we've given audi i
don't need to give it again
margin
okay fine
box shadow let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay so this is where exactly my
application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
100
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 percent we're taking background
color
let's bring it below
then align cell
display block
okay margin
okay
and uh border radius
and uh
fine i think we're all good now
so
that's it so we'll try and implement the
javascript part well everyone so our css
file is ready our html is ready it's
time to just uh
go ahead and talk about my
final question that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just see function
display
function display which takes
val as in parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result
okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay there's a function
after that you have another functions
available here called function solve
here
we just use the value called
x equal to
document dot get element by id
result
okay
dot
value sorry
dot
value
okay and say connect
y
equal to
perform the calculations for the using
one function called
er
and type
axis and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document.
get a runway
result
dot
value equal to
y
okay
now
later on
i'll like to use another function here
function
clear
screen
and here is a
document
so clear screen
solve
and
display three functions are associated
with me and these three functions
are the part of this javascript file
which i'll be calling it
at the end before
the water tank get closed so here
script
equal to
app.js
that's it okay let's try to execute now
here
two you can see the values
i will say plus
six
equal to eight absolutely otherwise say
c is clear that's great
six
divided by
two
equal to three awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is the css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like an office template
beautification and here last video for
js which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay
hello everyone and welcome to the
another very exciting project for our
development in javascript that is known
as call weather pro it is in the
continuation to the series of the
previous project what we have developed
in javascript and this is once again a
very competitive project i am going to
present to you
which is called weather pro where i
would like to offer you the real-time
weather application into your browser
taken from the real-time weather
applications
okay so let's get started with the new
development of our application which is
called a weatherproof
now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more kind of static in nature where like
you talk about snake game you talk about
tick tock toe or other type of games
like an online quiz
where the data was very much static in
nature but we were presenting the data
in the form of more dynamic in nature
this time
this project we are presenting you while
connecting with the real-time weather
application where i'll be making a one
rest api call or else you can say
asynchronous call and since javascript
is working as a what appear asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the javascript can communicate with your
backend load the data and represent the
records in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this
vs code editor only just to
develop our code and once again
for developing our presentation part
we'll be using html for
formatting part we'll be using css and
to make some dynamic update we'll be
using javascript now here i'm going to
create a new file name called index
dot html apparently i just want one more
that is called app.css
and another file we need it
and
that is called
your js file so we're saying
app
dot gs5
so total number of three files are
available to us i'll start working with
an html now and here
we'll start
with this html templates
now here first of all i would like to
load my css file which i do not have
right now but certainly i can use it
okay so i can just say link
area equal to
style sheet
and href
equal to
app dot css
well that is my css location
now i just want to create
some
this link area i would better use
inside my head tag that will be the more
convenient place
now in my body
i want to have some of the div tags and
there i can decide where the weather to
be displayed so i can just start with my
div diagonal
with my div tag i say
class equal to
i can just create a class which later on
i can offer
a different size of or different type of
style so we can say container
so we're saying div class equal to
container now within a div tag we like
to use another div tag which is a nested
one
so this step will have another class
called
class equal to
app hyphen
title
i have hyphen title
in the same div tag we can use
a typical paragraph tag
and here we say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag
we want to have a text box because i
would expect a client to enter the
detail on which city or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
sub properties like id
equal to
search
second type
equal to
text
next placeholder
equal to
enter
the city
next
autocomplete i'm saying autocomplete off
the reason because i do not want the
previous value user can see in this case
we can say autocomplete
off i do not want any autocomplete in
this
okay
now
here it is getting close now
after that we also want the locations
for that i may use some of the png files
and all but right now i just want to
display the details
of the user
like which city he belongs to and
accordingly i can display the records
right in your application
so for that i really need some of the
div tags once again where i can display
the details
of this particular city so i'm just
having this only text box let me go and
go back and check
how it looks
so i have a call enter the city so here
i'll be picking up the city and
somewhere down the line i have to
display
the record so
after this div
we can also have some of the locations
to be displayed
so
we can just use the notifications
and
also the location where you want the
details to be displayed
okay so we can use div class
class equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so div plus equal to temperature
hyphen value inside this i'll be using
paragraph tag
and here in my paragraph i'll say iphone
and
this degree centigrade or whatever you
want to display it here
and reduce
a spandex within this and show
in degree centigrade
that's it
and if you want to define the
temperature description
after this div tag we can use another
day of tank
and inside my dip tag
i can define the temperature description
okay so we can say tip
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
temperature hyphen description
and within this i will be using what
a paragraph tag here i'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which i want let me check
okay so it's here right now
so now let me try to collect the value
from the client
and perform some javascript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the css features
inside my code now
now few things i would like to say is i
have basically downloaded some fonts
which i would like to use it in my
application and i also have some of the
icons which i would like to use
during my application presentation so
there are some png files out there which
i have downloaded from the internet just
to bring more beautiful experience
towards my application development
well this is another background image
which is called bg.jpg which i would
like to
make it as a background of my
existing
application so i'll start with my css
and see how this css can really bring
some new features to my code well
first thing i need to have a call font
face so to make this font face we are
using this statement name call here at
the rate
font face
and
i like to use font family
font family i'm using
mod select
okay
it is already there with me mods are it
and the url
what is looking forward for so we are
saying src
url
and i'm saying under the
font so we have a file called ttf
okay that is called bolt.ttf that is the
file which is there
next thing
so
for every
location i want to use the font family
font iphone
family i want to use same
monster
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
i need url
and in this url we can say
bg.jpg
in my background
next thing is background color
that i needed steel blue
then i need height
i'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
this i needed is center
next is your background repeat
i say no repeat
next is your background size
this i'm saying cover
this is my body part
okay let's check
okay
looks awesome now you see this now this
is how
my weathering was looking like it you
can see like the background looks
awesome now now
next thing we required a container
so we are saying
dot
container
container we say width
width 50 percent
next background color
we're just using white
next we need it is your ally itself
that will be
center
display
will be block
margin
so in margin we can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius we're saying 10 pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box should be giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my container so
index.html file we have a call container
now
okay looks awesome now
so this is where exactly the details
will be
okay
now
after this css
container we have used
we can talk about called title
you can say
hyphen
title inside this we will say width
will be 100
then height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
10 pixels
then we need display
display we need flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying center
next we need justify content
that will be the justify content will be
just center
then flex direction
would be column
so this option we're using for our tool
name called what
app hyphen title
okay so here in my index.html file we
have called div class equal to what
our python title
equal to weather info let's check
okay
so
this is another
we have used that is called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph
so here
this app title
tab title space p
but it should be the class so we are
saying dot
and there also we have to use what
dot because both have to be the class
type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference i forgot to add
dot and now you can see it looks better
comparatively
paragraph
so once again in my paragraph i'll be
having texture line
center padding
i want 15 pixels
then i need margin
margin would be 0 and
auto
followed by font size
font size
this i'm saying is called 1.2
yeah
this position then color
we are giving
hash
value
call 333
okay
now here
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well going forward for the search
because if you remember we have an
index.html file we have a call id code
search so here in my
app.css i have to use
hash
search
okay so this search conditions i want to
use it
now inside my search i need few things
one is called display
i need block after that i think margin
left
auto
margin right
auto
width
i'm looking forward for 5 pixels
height
that i'm looking forward for 20 pixels
then border radius
i'm looking for four five pixels
then outline
that's called none
there is a border
okay
in this bottle what we can say three
pixels
let's paste solid
okay and once again
see
that's what
let's check
so this is actually the text box
so once again search you use display
block
margin
lift auto margin right auto width 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing i said
padding should be 5 pixels
width
should be 40
that's why it is smaller but it will be
40
let's check
yeah that's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready i'll be
having some of the details for the
notifications also
so what i need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
now in notifications i would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving white
and after that we using display
and we are saying
no
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by
its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all we
are saying color
color
is basically red
okay or else if you want to give maroon
it will the model
and
after this
the next property we are taking is
called font size
one size we are taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is 0
after that text line
center
adding 10 pixels
0.
so this is for notification p and then
the weather container
okay in my weather container i will say
width
hundred percent
sorry
yeah with 100 height
i'd be giving 260 pixels
or if to you 250 pixels if you want
background color
this background color we are giving is
called once again white
and followed by margin top
20 pixels
20
pixels this is for weather
container now for the weather icon
weather hyphen
icon
i am saying width
is 100
and height
128 pixels
just to give in a better look
now the next thing we're using dot
weather
icon icon
space img
here we can display
none
and
sorry display note none i will see
another block
display block and margin
giving zero
space auto
there's for
icon and location icon if i want to give
then
location iphone
icon
this location icon i can save with same
width height
so
width i'm giving is 100
then
height i'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option called
padding
then take pixels
so it's for location icon
now
followed by location icon we are also
giving call location icon img
okay dot
location hyphen
icon space img
here we we're giving the value called
display block
display block width
we're giving is called 32 pixels
and then we're looking forward for
margin
margin would be 10 pixels
and
auto
then cursor
so cursor will be pointed for sure
and then we required padding
padding looking forward for 5 pixels
followed by border
border we are looking forward for steel
glue
steel blue
solid
and 2 pixels
then border radius
border
radius
we're looking forward for 10 pixels
and followed by your color
steel blue
so these are the look and feel we have
to basically offer it for my
current application which i yet to
discuss in my
next development
then i'll be having some small small
properties here
okay
and those properties are nothing but to
give you the details of
like
temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen value
okay this temperature hyphen value we
can give it
is 100
and height
we're giving this call 60 pixels
this is for temperature value let me
copy this again
and
i'm giving this temperature value space
paragraph
here
i'm gonna give padding
0
margin
0
then color
which color you're looking forward for
we can just say dark gray
okay for any color which you're looking
forward for it's up to you now but if
you want you can change the color also
to another one we're giving this call
hash
293
okay two five one
okay that is a more perfect color for
this
development now font size
4 em
then followed by texture line
and once again center
this is for
temperature value b
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value p
then you can use a temperature value
span
here
dot
temperature value span
space
span
and here
we go additional dot
now within this span
say color
once again same
and font size
this is for
span
and in the same temperature description
paragraph you can use it
dot
temperature iphone description
description space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
then margin
0
followed by color
same color the one which we have used
earlier
after this color just a texture line
center font size
1.2
this is for temperature
description
okay
last which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now dot
location
is space b
here we can say margin
0
then padding
0
then color
same color i would like to use
after this color texture line
and font size
and copy
text align center and here we'll be
giving some different value called 0.8
okay and last which is really left with
call tip
in that
relative
here position
i'll be using
absolute
top
from top
i'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
i'm using 120 pixels
that's it
okay so all set
so you can see now
here we have to basically offer the
details how my pictures will be taken
attack so this is what my css now will
be applying some of the css into my
applying the css into my html to see how
it really looks like it if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
okay so we have seen some of the thesis
classes we have introduced
in my html
we have used this uh
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used tip class equal to temperature
value
okay if you just check carefully we have
used this temperature and there we have
used temperature hyphen
value
but before that we would like to use
some other properties too
okay after this autocomplete equal to
off we want to use
another dev class
okay before my previous date tag is
closed here so here
after this we would like to use another
div tag
div
here in my tip
i'll say
class
equal to
location hyphen icon
location hyphen
icon
okay and here i'll be using img
src
equal to what under
icons i'm using the file name called
location
dot png
and alt equal to we leave it as it is
the blank
okay
now here the div tag is getting closed
okay
now there's another div tag is getting
closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another div class for
notification here
class equal to notification
dev class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another tip for the weather
condition
another div tag and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
whether hyphen what
a condition
or i can say whether iphone container
whichever so i can say
whether hyper container
under this
weather container i like to use
another tip
for weather icon
tip for
class equal to weather hyphen icon
weather hyphen icon
and within this
i want to use another img
src equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot png
okay div tag is getting closed
so after this div tag is closed i'm
gonna use
temperature value
so the temperature value is anyways used
here if you see
raising call temperature value after the
first step tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used
after that the paragraph tag and the
temperature hyphen
description b
after the p that the div tag is getting
close
okay and after this we're using div
class equal to location
so we want to use
div
class equal to
location
and within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
[Music]
with this hyphen
after this paragraph exists close this
tip tag this tip tag
and another tip tag three div tags are
closed
that's it and at the last
before my body tag is closed
i would like to use
script
src equal to
app
dot
js
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now
so
this i
want to be display only when i don't
find the weather and the location
anymore so look and feel is absolutely
good and now i'll start working on my
javascript front
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our javascript code
so in this javascript code first of all
i need few things
uh first thing what i need is called
individual elements or individual
properties of my application i need cost
icon element
i can element equal to
document dot
query selector
i'll be using the name
call
dot
weather hyphen
icon
okay
now
copy this
now we will call icon element we can say
location icon
call
location
icon
here we are saying
dot location
hyphen
icon
now
next
i need is called temp element
we are using
the property call dot
temperature hyphen
value
space
p
next we're looking forward for
dec element which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyphen
description
hyphen
temperature has been description space
got
then location element
okay we need location element and we use
dot location
space b
next we need notification element
notification element and here we're
going to give the call
notification
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements
next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this is statement is all about
selecting the elements the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying var
input
equal to
document dot
get element by id here we give the name
called
search which is the name or id of my
text box let
city equal to
blank
next we're going to keep score let
latitude
equal to 0.0 we are initializing this
value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input fields
next we want to apply the events here we
are saying input
the variable
dot
add event listener
the variable what we're talking about
which even list will be talking about
key up
okay
up
and what even do you want to apply so we
are saying
function
with a parameter name called what
event
and now we would like to attach the
logic now
we send if
what is the condition
event
dot
key code
equal to
13
okay
then
that means number 13 is basically the
enter
see the key code means for 13 13
represent the enter keyword so even dot
key code equal to what 13 so here
same event
dot
preview
default why we're using this because i
do not want my page to be get
refreshed just to avoid this we're using
this and after that we are saying city
equal to
input dot
value
now
you'll be using this another function
because i do not have function created
otherwise i have to call the function
name called get search weather and be
passing this as a parameter so we are
going to get
search
whether i do not have this function i
yet to create this
and pass it here as a what
city
and we say
console
dot
log city whatever we are basically
printing it
okay
so that is the first thing
later on we need to get the data so to
get the data we are just using this
variable name called const
weather
equal to
const weather equal to
curly braces
after that we are saying
weather
dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want i'm saying unit
of type what
celsius
i wanted a celsius put it in a double
quotes
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in kelvin i'm saying
const kelvin
equal to value of the kelvin is about
273
and after that
go on see ultimately what we need is
we need to interact with our backend api
from where i will
get or receive the updated weather
applications
okay
now
to get this i'll be using one very
popular api here that is known as called
openweathermap.org
this is a very very popular app
which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear
so here
what you can do this
open weathermap.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular
unique
api key
since
as a visitor you really can't get it
unless you register yourself so i have
my api key with me so i'll go here
it'll ask me for the registration
so
i already signed up so if you're not you
need to sign it there's an api key for
me which i need to copy and this api key
i'll be using it in my project
so i just use this property called const
key equal to
to paste my key here
okay
after this paste in the key but make
sure that you rather using my key you
use your key otherwise this application
sometimes won't work
so i'm basically trying to use this tool
name called geolocation
i'm saying if
geolocation
okay and
navigator
navigator is you know there's a browser
object model element
so here we are using
navigator
okay
navigator dot
geo location dot
get current position
in which i'll be passing the first
parameter name convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case
if any error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
i'm using this statement name called
notification
element
you see this notification element dot
style
dot
notification remain dot
get elements by class name
but i don't need this rather i will use
what the style
dot display equal to
block
then i will be using the same
notification element dot
inner html equal to
you're gonna use a paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
so you have to enable the current
location of use
okay that's where exactly
so after that we have to basically set
what the user position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location we'll be just using another
function here
function
set
position
it will i'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position dot
chords chords for coordinate star
latitude
okay like that
longitude
equal to
what position dot
cords
dot
longitude
after this we'll be using this function
called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon seen
i'll be having it defined below but as
of now we are just saying
get weather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this function name called
what
set
position
in which will be passing all the values
okay at the same time
i will be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
i would like to use location
icon the one which you define on the top
card
add event listener which even listener
i'm saying
one click
second
function
which take
even doesn't parameter
and inside this i'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey
just
and
we say get weather
okay once again you'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same i just copy
this
and paste it here
okay everyone so we have written till
here when i try to run my browser
so i should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined
but obvious because this message what
we're writing it here is called show
error
okay this
as a function as a parameter it is not
defined let me define this function
called show error so we are saying
function
show error which take
error as in sorry just take
error is in parameter
now in this we are using
notification
dot
style
dot display equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element
dot
inner html
equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
error
dot
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and now
see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if i say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment i click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because i told you
this get weather function i need to
develop so i get to develop this
function called get weather but before
that i'm using another function called
function
get search weather
get
search weather in which i'll be passing
what
city name
now
what exactly my apa will be in case if i
want to make a call i will be using let
api equal to
now the url will be what
http
colon double forward slash api dot
open
weather map dot
org now open weather map dot org
slash
data
slash two point
sorry two point
five that is a version slash
weather
okay question mark
i have to take the city dynamically so
i'm saying weather
question mark q
equal to
we're using what city
and
we're using ampersand
app id
equal to the one app id we have used it
already
okay what is that
that key
so that is the key
which you've already written that app id
we are passing it right over here
okay q equal to city and applied equal
to this
now after that to make the restful api
call i'll be using one independent or
uh by default api which is available to
us that is known as call what
fetch
okay so if you just check this fetch it
is basically a take request info
and give you the what a promise response
so return type will be the promise type
in this fetch i'll be passing what
the api
and we'll be using dot
then that means if the request
is successful using function
function
response
then function is in parameter response
we are saying let
data equal to
response dot i'm expecting the response
of type of what json
is in json now and return what
data
so it will be returning data back to me
now
if it is successful then what then i'm
saying dot then once again it is
chaining
again
function
again
data is in parameter
now in this case we'll be getting lot of
things
i'm saying
whether
okay dot
temperature it's a predefined dot
value
equal to i'm using what
math
dot
floor inside this we are passing what
data dot
main
dot temp it is a predefined property we
are receiving it now
hyphen
kelvin whatever the kelvin value is
basically we're taking score 273 on the
top
minus
kelvin
followed by
another property what
weather dot
description
weather dot
description
equal to we're using
data dot
weather zeroth position because it
contains lot of data but i will be
taking what
description out of that
then
weather dot
icon id
whether dot icon id equal to
data
dot
weather
dot
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather dot
city
okay equal to
data dot
name after this
weather dot country
dot
equal to
data dot
sys dot
so these are the properties i have it
right now with me
okay and once i received all the
property i'll be using dot
then
i'll be using one function
and i will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but i'm gonna say
there's a one function name called
display
weather
this function i had to write
but this function just putting it here
okay
now this is closed
after that
since i need to get a weather from the
apa provider
so i have to also password the latitude
and longitude which i'm receiving it
from the client because
here i just want to have two things
the properties as well as whether both
and both i'll be using it one by one
okay so here
we have kept this get search weather and
now i'll be calling one more function
after this logic and i'm giving the name
called function
getweather
okay it takes two parameter one is
called what latitude
and thing is called
longitude so we have two things called
latitude and longitude
and here i'm using this property called
what let
api
equal to
once again
if you remember
i have used this statement i'll just
copy the same
and
pass it it here
but challenge would be this time
i will not be passing city name because
the two options are available either you
type the city name or else you click on
the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this feather question mark
here i will not be using q i'm using
what
led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using
and
hello in
equal to
we're using longitude
okay and app id equal to what key so
this is the variable which we have it
now
okay
now
similar thing which we have used it on
the top
okay called fetch api
so i just copy this same fetch api again
because i really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code when we
know it very well it can be similarly
done i just copy and
paste it here
so the same fetch api
dot then response data equal response or
json return data then
whether that temperature method flow
says country dot display weather so we
have used the same thing here and after
that we have to use the last function
here that is called display weather
display
weather
and here in my display weather i can use
what
icon element dot
inner html equal to
i'll be using
img
src
equal to
icons
slash
dollar
and we'll be passing what whether
okay dot
icon id
okay
dot
png
okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot png and after that
it is closing that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
so rather than closing this i'll be
closing that and
this i'll be closing it here
now we'll be using top element
sorry temp element
temple event
dot
inner html
equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
weather dot
temperature
dot
value
okay
and
after this value we can just use
this asterisk sign
the one which i told you
okay and use
span
span
okay next we're using call talk element
so we have that sorry dsc element
we have got dac element dot
inner html equal to
weather dot
description
and last but not least location
element dot
inner html
equal to
what
i'll be using once again this
and here
weather dot
city
comma
dollar
weather dot
that's it these two properties we have
to use it
and we're all done
let's check with my code
if i get any error
now
allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds globe undefined that's
perfectly fine intercity
you can see awesome beautifully it is
showing you the conditions it's saying
smoke 28 degree centigrade and now let
me put another city here i'm gonna say
called pulley
awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and
let's see one more
i would say
awesome if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
and now we are planning to develop one
very special game for you
in javascript and now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known for tic tac
tic tac toe is
world's favorite game we have already
played a lot in our childhood days and
still my favorite game so i have decided
to basically offer you this tic-tac-toe
game
developed in
javascript html plus css which can
create something really very great
effects for the end users so let's go
and start developing our next game that
is called tic tac toe
so in this tech tactile i will start
working with creating a folder called
tic tac and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called index
dot html
now here onwards the same thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but so we're going to create some div
diagram
so in this div tag
i'll be creating some of the tags
in which the css class will be applied
so we just gonna create a classes
uh for i'm gonna just use those classes
but we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create those so we're saying
div
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
dev tag inside this i'll keep
my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tip here we
say
h1
and inside this h1 it gives the message
called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic-tac-toe game
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for player 1
or else i can say player 1 and inside
this let's give the name called
player
label is closed
and
after this label will start working with
our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to player1
next we want id
equal to
player one
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're gonna close this this is
my first text box
and um same thing i would like to create
for my another one
so the first dip tag we have used let me
go and create another tip
tag in this div tag i'll use the same
label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after this div
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
dev tag is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now
so here we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show
some containers where the details will
be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check that
is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name in the name after the stick tag
tool
so
yeah
so here the details we have taken input
typically text and input applicable text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div
and inside this div
i since i haven't created any css
classes so those we can use it little
later on but let's have
this div
and inside this step i would like to use
one more tip type
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so
in this div we can just give the value
called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value
we are passing it
div
data equal to zero the div tag is
getting closed
fine so that's how we want it now
so here
the first tip tag is closed like that we
can create another data id so 0 1 2
total number of 3 we want to create it
so i want to create 0 1 2 3 4 5 like
this
so the way we have created here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
id equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
two
three
four
five so zero one two three four five dot
number five we have created
almost i would like to create it down
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
okay
and uh
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
board or button that you can basically
offer it little later on
but here we can use one more div
and here we say do
dip classical relative
and within this step tag i can use
any image tag if i want
so i just leave it as it is
and after this
i can create one more div type
and inside this another tip
okay
and
under this i'm gonna create
a button
okay and in this button
we'll be having some value
okay we can secure the value name called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
spam
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
it's just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there is no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me more better look when your
application will start
but most importantly i need to start
working with a javascript part where the
logic will get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included the javascript with
my code
so here
i can see here
a script tag
script
equal to
now the file i haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style cheat also so
i just say
link
real quick style sheet
into the name called
css though i haven't created but i'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our
consideration now we'll be creating this
css as well as the javascript to make
this example complete
well we are ready with our html but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js
and inside this we will start writing
the logic with our main application
okay
now the first thing is how we're going
to start now
yeah
so
first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist
but i can give the name called app
which i'm going to create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i'm saying let
gameboard
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making the plane
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay
now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create let
turn just a new variable
equal to
zero
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player its turn
like which player turns it to b so just
it is trying to mention it i'm saying
let
weller equal to
false
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
layer how are you going to create a
player vc const
player equal to
what we're going to pass
name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
name
that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
initialize
now inside this initialize the app we're
going to create a new function
function
app
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise saying let
input feed
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id
here we're gonna take
the
class name of this particular
text field so we are saying input
hyphen
field
okay dot
focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add players
equal to once again
document
dot
get eleven by id let me just give the
new player form
okay
next we are saying
add
player
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
after that once the players are added we
are saying
let replay
replay button equal to once again
document
sorry
document
get a remain by id or rather i will say
document.queryselector
document.queryselector
replay type
btl
okay just the name we are basically
taking that and here we say
sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener which even i want to
say
click
okay that is the first event second
reset board
reset
board
that we are basically passing that
okay
now
this is the initial case which we have
it
now beyond that i will add
this is the place what we have added
right now slides to add the players so
this is how we have initialized after
that let's
add
plates
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add
players
okay so take
event as a parameter
and say event
dot
prevent
prevent default this present default
will try to prevent
the default
uh you know
behavior which is submitting to we get
avoided and now here we say if
this dot
player
one so we're just defining the property
called player one
if this dot player one dot what
value
okay
is
blank
okay or
just start
day
sorry
let's start
player 2
now i just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i am saying alert
you
almost
enter
name
for
each
field
the user has to add the values and after
that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this inside
this by saying cost
layer
form container
again
const play from controller container
equal to
document dot
query selector
documentary selector here we will just
pass
the value call
enter
iphone
okay now we say cost
board main equal to
document
dot once again
query selector
code
underscore main
okay after that
player
form container
dot
class list
dot class list dot
add here we're given the name forward
height container
right
container
and after that you just say board mail
boardman
dot class list
dot
remove
hide
hyphen container
and after this what i will do i'll just
say player
x
dot
name
equal to
this dot
player 1
dot
value
ok this for player x copy this
player
2
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which
we've implemented
well so add player function is added
right now
and after this add player we have to
basically call
one more that is called which returns
the current player so i'm saying return
current player
and here what i will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
just variable
okay percentile
2 we're just adding it with this
zero
okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you
okay or else
so we're adding like the current player
who says the current tail right now
well
after this adding the return current
player we're going to add another
function that is known as call return
the current player return current player
is having this value and after that we
need to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized once again if the browser is
getting resized automatically the square
size of your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we gonna say this option equal
window
dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here
and the second parameter what we are
parsing is call on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is a function name for me
the one which we are passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
in this we are passing
board
underscore
cell
okay and then we're using another option
called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set width
or set width
after that we are saying all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
cell
[Music]
and after that we are using cell
dot
style
dot
height
equal to now here using this backtick
and use this
dollar sign
and say
cell
height
and then
pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's it over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
build port
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document dot
once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
class
list dot remove
and we are passing the value called
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also
okay so for those functions i can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add
self click listener
but i do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
your own
okay so we will just leave those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt
to make move so
here we're trying to say
cell
click
event
for
player 2.
attempt
to
make
move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function
and give the name of the function to
make move now
function
make
move
it takes
give it as a parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and say enter
now let's go back and try to check
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what
event dot
current target
sorry
even dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values after that
we use another variable called let
sell to
add
token
now here we are typing document
dot
query selected
and here
you know using backtick
i'm using this value called
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay so this value we are taking it like
that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell
to add token dot
inner html
extrometry mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token dot inner html equal to blank
then what next
so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay so
in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current set dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell
is
already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to active console
using cell to add token
okay dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and we say
game board
the one which you have created pass in
this game board
this value call
current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
send
to add token dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for
is winner to check whether the user is
winner or not so we are saying
is
winner
okay and
after that we are saying
turn
plus plus
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being
and we'll call this little later on so
leave it as a full time name
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not okay so we are saying
function
check
if
i
we're just taking the function
whether it is game is tied or not so
here we say
if the condition is turned
greater than 7
alert
again
okay we can say give over first we can
say our type
okay
well after that we are saying winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we will check
const
winning sequences
winning sequences
and here
sorry
here
we are having this array and having the
different conditions associated we say 0
two probability we are checking it
and then i just copy it
well we saying 0 1 2 and here is saying
8 and zero three six again
zero
three
six
and once again one four seven
four 7
and next we have a call 258
8
then we are checking the value 0 for it
eight and one more last option we'll put
is called two four six
six so these conditions we are adding it
now
after this array we can say
winning sequences start
for each
and give the name call winning compose
winning
combos
and inside this varying compound we are
giving let
cell 1 equal to
varying combos position 0
then
that copy
and paste 3 times
cell 2
cell three
and here we get the writer called what
one
is true three values we're giving it and
after that
we're checking the condition
let's say
if and here the conditions you're
checking
what exactly that would be for the game
board using
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
current player
ampersand time percent
come
down
game board
cell 2
i just want to copy the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
cell 3
and
after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
by cutting this condition called
calm sense
const
and then equal to
document dot
get element by or sorry document or
query selector
query selector
all
and here let's select the position dot
board
and discard
cell
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside is what we are passing they
are saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
we're saying if
cell
id now we're talking about call cell id
triple equal to
cell 1
or
cell id
cell 2
or
salary equal to
cell three
okay and in that case we can use
cell dot
class list
dot
add
get the name cardboard
just give the class name
winner
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
current layer equal to
document dot
get element by id
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current layer or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
layer we can use
the current
layer text
the new variable we are creating it
current player text document dot rather
than saying get element by id
we can say
query selector
and in this query selector will be given
the value
by saying dot board
in that
query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it in a
parenthesis
like this
now here we just checked
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
current player what is the value we are
using current text
dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you say
congratulations
along with
and here the div tag is getting closed
like this
okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it
and after that
we give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to
true
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written we'll
be talking about a little later on and
just say return proof
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if filler
if
winner
or you can say
check
if type
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board
header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us and here we
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case we have to say let
current player text
equal to
document
dot
query selector in this we'll be getting
the details like dot
board
and here we gonna give the name called
player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put in a capital letter
here
x
then we will say
current player
dot
inner html equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backtext because i want to
go multilines that's the benefit of this
backtick and here we say in our inner
html span
class
equal to name
hyphen hyphen
style
close this and here we want to use
the statement
now this
value
we want to write it with name attribute
so it is getting close and here we are
saying dollar
with this player
x
dot
name
and then
close the
span tag
and we say
you are
up
like this
and after that
we say dev
class equal to
which is going to create a class which
later on we can apply the css style on
the top of that u hyphen r
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div tag
so dip tag is closed
that's it and now
after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current layer
text
dot inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we gonna write the span
same option we're gonna use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
this thing rather than copying it again
and again
i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to name hyphen iphone
style
player rather than saying x you can use
file
you are up you are
winner
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we need to do
create another function called reset
port
function
reset board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using
the game board
and the same game board what we have
used it earlier
i'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember
that was a game code for me so i'll be
using the same keyboard
they copy this
yeah
with the same condition
okay give me equal to this after that
line we will say let
sell to add token
sell to add token equal to
document
dot query selector all
here
in this i'll be using
another class called
letter
now
cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square
and within this square we would like to
use square
dot
text content
equal to black
after that
square
dot
parent element
dot
class list
dot
remove
and here we would like to say board
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these css classes we're just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to 0 because we are resetting it
and
winner equal to
false
after that winner is equal to false we
just define another variable called
define let current player text
player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all so here
we're gonna use the name called board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
current player text dot
inner html equal to
once again we have to use the condition
for
up
and winner point
so let me try to copy this
inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's check
the condition board
or
cell
and here once again we say cell stop for
each
dot
for each
and here this is cell
dot
add
event listener
which event i want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
handler
once called
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell
click listener
now here we say
let
all
cells
equal to
document dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell
and now we say
all cells
dot
for each
cell
and here we say cell dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here
most of our javascript code is written
now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create
our html file now sorry the css so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i'm going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.css in either folder like in static
folder but i have just kept it outside
now from this point onwards i would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called morning
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay
but i don't think so it's really needed
it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background because
it's by default gonna be white only
and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position i just say like
center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
here using cover
okay so it resize the background image
to cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes first select div
dot relative
the straight alternative is first say
call position
position we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right is saying 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height
dot
container oh sorry hide hyphen container
here in hide hyphen container we will
display
display
colon none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the cellar we will say color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family i am selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
permanent marker
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that's called dot
enter
hyphen
layers
now an inter hyphen players are the same
color
will once again
we can use any other layer but we can
just use white or any color you want
or you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we are giving it's called zero
auto width
we're looking forward for 80
next texture line
center
position
relative
now
next we're going forward for input field
in this input field we just say border
border two pixels
solid
and black
next
outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
4 pixels 8 pixels now margin
we are saying 0
0 10 pixels
okay and finally
for pixels
after this margin we say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
focus
now here
border
two pixel
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want your submit button to be so
i'm saying
dot
submit hyphen btn
border
two pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
80 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 pixels
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take
white only
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate
with your submit button active and
submit button focus so we are saying dot
submit
hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outline
outline
then
next border
we're talking about two pixels
solid
and the color red
okay
so that's the one
and uh after that we like to use power
dot
submit hyphen button colon
over
what you want
change the background color
to what
white
you can use white smoke
well
here we like to use
a
dot
board
here we like to use player
hyphen so these are the classes we were
using in our javascript we remember
and here we say color
color we're using once again
white or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
texture line
center margin
10 pixels
0
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style
and here we are saying color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about a
next important called border container
called board container plot
board container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say coordinate blue
okay
next margin
we are taking is 0
and
auto
after that font size
font size we are taking 0
next border
bottom we are taking 2 pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
if you remember this worksheet is one of
the very very easy
three popular property here we're
defining three pixels
three pixels
three pixels
zero pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about called black
okay
so my
border color will be shading color will
be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining 100
okay divided by
three
this calculation
after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
center border
we are taking
two pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top font family
this formula can use permanent
permanent marker
okay
now
next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board syllable
board
[Music]
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
50
next transform
translate by
to minus 50
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay
now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're giving
winner
with dot
dot
winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container what
are the values we want to use it
that's you want to basically do it so
for this winner container what i would
rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
texture line
center
margin
20 pixels
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset heading we will set
display none
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah i'm going to talk about replay
button dot
replay hyphen
vta
and here width
we make it
to
25
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called 2
pixels
followed by solid
okay and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on outline
i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this letter spacing would be again
zero
after that
text transform
this text track form value we are
talking about call
uppercase
next font
size font size
we're taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay
now in a similar line we can also have
call dot
replay iphone btn
colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
then color
we are making it is called white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
so we'll be using this
dot
okay
so this congratulations class will be
using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r
dot
winner
in this winner we will be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking 18 pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two pixels
and then zero
okay that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
iphone btn
this i am saying with 50
percent
so this is what my css file is all set
i know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch
so we have this index.html file with us
and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known as call
this permanent marker this class is not
by default available so we have to
include this
using this external api so here
where we have a call css with us
before that
we want
link
so within this link we want a one
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent
plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know where exactly it is
using
okay if i just copy and paste it
so i just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com
slash oh spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url from where i can
take this kind of font so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it
so
here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the final outcome of my code
which is
index.html5
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class are attached so i need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes so that at
least i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a call tip h1
class equal to header
tic tac toe then we have a call tab we
have a call
body
under this we have a call another div
tag so
just imagine how many type of classes
are available one we have called tip
class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a call
one more div tag so like that multiple
css files are there where we have to
apply the new css class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added
all those type of css classes which we
had that is called inter player
player form
player container
label
placeholder and player container
and if you see all different type of
classes we have attached this to
okay because here only my css class will
get applied and the javascript will
apply those kind of dynamic css based on
certain conditions so these css classes
are already there added inside your html
page
our app css is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic-tac-toe is a game it is expecting
and it says start game it says you must
enter a name for each field validation
is working let me try to add
two names and say start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying a you are
up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the tic tac
door game is used so it is a classical
example of css
javascript and html together so this
time we're going to talk about our next
very interesting feature that is called
dealing with another example that is
called snake game so staying keep is one
of the very very powerful
example which i'm gonna share with you
which will help you to understand like
how we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project
okay that is something which is a snake
game let's see how the snake game is
important and how we're going to deal
with this
these are our previous examples which we
have seen which i will call a project
which we have created that is called
quiz application
and now we're going to start working
with our new project
now here first of all i'm going to
create a new folder
that is called snake
again
and inside this estate game we need some
new
folders
first folder i'm going to create it
inside this that is called images
and
within this snake games i'm going to
create few new files that is called
index
dot html
and here
i'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot js
at the same time i'll be having some of
the css files if i need so i can say
app dot
css so total number of three files i
have it now let me close down all the
files whichever i have opened it earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach
so
this is the snake game for us from where
we need to start
and we have index.html file and here i
will i think you will create
our basic html syntax
and
here i would like to include
our script tag
script
src equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing
our next
implementation of
snaking
now inside my body tag
i would like to have some basic property
called speed
okay and later on i'll be taking the
input from the client so we are saying
input
type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give id
equal to
gamespeed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value
and
min
equal to
1 that is the minimum value
and max equal to 9 that is the maximum
and minimum value we can offer beyond
that i won't allow the users to go
and step
that means the increment value that is
one
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button
and
value
equal to
start
and then id equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after
that can give some
bricks
so two bricks we are giving it and start
working with the div diagonal
and in this div tag i'll be using the
canvas
it is a html5 feature
we use canvas
and i just give id equal to
game
area
there is a canvas
and
after this canvas
we will
that tip tag is closed here after the
div tag i can use another tab tag
there here i can say
class equal to
i may not have any class written but i
can say
class equal to related so later on if i
want to apply any css style
i can certainly apply and after that i
can offer the images
okay so i may not have any images right
now so i just leave this image blank
right now
okay and this script src i'll load it
only
before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on the bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so i can see
values
now it will go maximum nine that is how
we have given and minimum is one
start is a button which is not doing
anything but later on we can allow some
logic inside this
now we have to start working with our
main javascript tag
this is my amp.js and here onwards we
will use
some of the properties okay which i want
to initialize it so using var
game
start
equal to
initialized
second game speed
equal to
next game area
equal to
null
game area context
equal to null
then gave area width
game area
width
equal to
0 that is in integer value game area
height
game area
equal to 0 again
then solve
it cell width equal to 0
play score
equal to 0 again
next snake
equal to null
next snake food
equal to null
next snake direction
equal to null
snake speed or else i can say speed size
speed size
equal to
zero
next we have our timer
equal to
so these number of properties we've
initialized
okay
now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here in initialized
we would like to use some of the
properties
first we are saying
game start
equal to
document dot
get element by id
here i can give the value call
hash
game start let me put it in double
quotes
again
start
now game speed now these are all
basically the values are there game
start game speed
these all values we have to take it
okay so we will be seeing these values
one by one so let me say another one
that is for game speed
game speed equal to again
document dot
get element by id now we are passing
the game speed game
game speed
now
here
once again i will take another point
game area
i say game
game area
here you have to give the value called
game area
okay so these values we have taken
now we'll be talking about called game
media context
give me the context equal to
game area
dot
get context
okay
and in this game context we will be
using what type of context using 2d
okay because i want to have
the kind of 2d so
this is how the kind of environment we
want to set
next we talk about game area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
game area height
equal to 600
now solve it
we are initializing with 20
next game area dot width
okay so game area
dot
width equal to
game area width
and then we define k media dot height
dot
equal to
game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this
okay
now after that we have to start writing
the logic here i'm saying game start
game start
dot now we have to line uh which event
you would like to take so i will say on
click
on
click
so when i basically click what should
happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here i'm
saying this dot
this dot disabled
equal to
true
so i want to disable these values
and after that we want to call
another function inside this
but which function let's do that so here
we are saying function
start game
start
game
and
here in start game
we want to define the initial score see
the initial score for the player will be
certainly zero so we say
player
score
equal to zero
after that
direction in which direction you want
the snake to move so we are saying snake
direction equal to
right
in the right direction
then speed size
the value also the variable which you
define so speed size equal to because
it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it certainly will be string type
so we have to use power send
so we're using this option called power
sent and here we're using
gamespeed
dot
[Music]
value
okay so we are using this value
gamespeed.value now here we would like
to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay
what if condition
[Music]
see this function we are writing called
start game
because there are certain things which
you need to
make it
so like that we predefine it so function
initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
on click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started
start game and now we'll be writing the
logic for this so here we are saying if
we're seeing speed size
missing equal to nine
we basically initialize to what nine
here we say else if
speed size
is
zero
we say speed size
sorry
speed size
equal to 1
that means if it is less than 0 i will
be making it minimum to 1 if it is
greater than 9 i will be making it to 9
maximum and that's it
okay
so after this else if condition
is getting closed
we are seeing speed size equal to
one
so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards
by saying x
position
0
and
then the y
and here the y value will be what
cell wait that means how far it can go
so it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call salvage we
have given here
after that what we have to do is
we have to define our own function
called
clear interval
and this clear interval perform any
logic whichever i would like to make it
okay so here
after the snake dot push value has been
given
here i will be creating one more
function here
that is known as call
create food okay so here we're saying
create
food
so create food will be the function for
me now you might be thinking where this
function is but this function will be
declared soon within your application
but here first we are saying the
function called clear interval
clear interval
with the timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that
this clearing treble will be saying
timer
equal to
set interval
with this we are saying create game area
create
now
here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement we are giving this
call create food is a function we are
calling after that we are calling this
clear interval
clear interval will be just like in a
typical function which is there using
this option called create game area
so
[Music]
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you how
you can call this function create food
and how to create it first well so we
are talking about a functionality called
create game interval so this create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the saying set
interval
this function is not it there so we have
to basically go back and create this
function within my application
fine so
what we will do is just particular one
we will try to comment it for a time
being
okay so here we have a call what create
interval
in this create interval will be
passing any parameters which we are
passionate about as a timer here and
here we are calling this call create
food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
in this function create food let's go
and write the logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food this is snake food
snack food equal to
and here in our curly braces we use two
direction x and y
we say in x we say
math dot
around
and inside this we say
math
dot
random
after this math.random function we have
to just take this calculation
and check the another parameter called
game area with
game
area width
minus
cell width the one which you are passing
it and here after that we'll be
performing the calculation by saying
celebrate
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similarly we would like to use for my y
coordinate also
now
math dot round round dot number game
area
game area height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
minus
seventh let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay
so that's where exactly it got closed
okay
now here
our applications is now ready by calling
the function called create4
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so we are saying
create game area
create
game
area this is another function for me
after this create game area there will
be another function i'm going to create
it
that is called control
function
control
okay after that we are going to write
one more function called function
right score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call right score
there's another function which you're
going to write it on here that is called
function
right score is done now we say create
square
create
square
this is another function
and finally we'll have a call change
direction
function
change
change
direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it
here in our system
well
we know very well that we have taken
this called create food grade food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
great game area we are defining two
location bar
x direction and y direction so we say
a snake
x
equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we say dot x
for the x direction
we are saying var
snake
y
equal to
snake
position we are taking once again zero
and
dot okay so two directions we have taken
x direction and y direction
now here we are starting
gain
area
context dot
fill style at the united variable it is
a property
fill style equal to which color you want
to fill this up
so i'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this gamer
context again
dot fill react
fill react
now keep the position values i'm saying
0 comma 0 comma
game area
game area width
comma
game area height
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stroke style let me take the game area
context again
dot
stock style
stroke style
equal to now we give the another color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same gave me the context dot stroke
react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
0
0
comma
game area width
comma
game
area
height
so we're passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic
of the directions
now see the when you talk about snake
game it move left right and center
up and down so now in this case we have
to increment the situations accordingly
so we say if
the snake direction
if the snake direction
go to
right
then we say snake
x
plus plus
now
else if
also
same
let's copy this
snake direction
left
then what should happen
here we say
snake
x
minus minus
okay so we're taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're taking about left right we
set down
so in this case we say snake
y
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
let me say
snake
y
minus minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this else if condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition
we are using some more lengthy
statements
what's that we say
if snake x
f snakes x
-1
or
snake x
double equal to
game
area
width which we have taken
divided by
cell weight
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus one
okay so we're giving this call minus 1
or
snake y
stack y equal to
gain area height
to save it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah i will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created some time back and inside this
control
it will take some parameters so what
those parameters we can pass okay we can
say
snake
x
comma
snake y
comma
third parameter will be
snake
so this could be my another function
okay
so here
we are passing the conditions just like
that
okay now here
this is
available to use a parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for write
score
which is so far the function is only
created not
described more so we are writing the
right score the score will be written
here
and here we are saying clear interval
because the timer will be stopped
okay and using game start
dot
disabled
equal to
false
and after that
return
that's it
so this is the logic for we have written
to this particular example
now we can use
another if more conditions here just to
check the behavior of my code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
well here we have finished this
game start dot disabled equal to false
and we returned
now going forward after this return
we would like to have another condition
for the snake x so we say if snake x
if a snake x double equal to
snake food
dot x
okay snake foot cortex
ampersand perfect
snake
y
double equal to
snake
food dot
y
then in this case i will say
var new head
bar
new xory
var
new head equal to here
x
colon
snake x
y
colon snake body
snake x and y colon
snake
y
these options we are taking it
now
after that we are using this option
called player score
plus
equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
create food method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this as condition
we are saying var
new head
equal to
snake
dot pop
okay and we are saying new head
dot x
equal to snake x
and new head
dot y equal to
snake
y
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
dot unshift
and shift
snake dot and shift and here we are
passing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for loop by saying for
var equal to
r i
i equal to 0
then
i is less than
snake dot
length
and
snake dot length
and once i
plus plus
okay
later on we just use the option called
create
square
and in discrete square we are passing
snake
snake position
i
dot
x
comma
same
snake
dot y
that's it
so it's getting closed here and after
that we are calling the same option
with this snake food let me copy this
again
and here rather than
using this we can say snake food dot x
and snake foot dot y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now let me start working
with your control
control needs to take three parameters
x y and the array so we are passing this
option called
control and in this control we are
taking x
comma y
comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
var
i equal to zero
i
is less than
array total
length
and i
plus plus
and after that we'll be using this
option called if condition and here we
say
array
i
which value we are passing dot x
double equal to
x
ampersand time percent
here we say array
with a position called i
and in this we are saying dot y
and this position we are checking for
the y condition
for the y condition so it returns what
true
written
through
the condition
okay that is for if condition has
written one
false
now that's it now we are talking about
this option name called write score
this right score we have to use a game
area context
game
area context dot
font
equal to
here we'll be passing this situation
we're saying 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
cells iphone
service
after that we're using called game media
context again let me copy this
take it again call game area context dot
fill style equal to here i'll be using
another color now
we say hash
okay
now after that we are saying once again
the kmd context dot
fill
text here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say
plus
player score whatever it is
with game area with
game area width
slash
2
minus
100
and then
again game area with
slash
so this is where exactly the right score
where the data will be actually written
okay next we'll be having this option
called grade square at this great square
it takes two parameters one we're
talking about call x
second is taking y
and now here we're using this game area
context
same
dot
fill style
equal to let me give the color
after this we're using call same gary
and text
game area text dot
fill react
here we are saying x
multiplied by
cell with comma
y multiplied by
cell with
comma
cell width comma
circuit
this is what
my grade square is now we are left with
only one option that is known for change
direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters
now here we are passing this option
called workkeys
equal to e
dot
and
later on we want to say if
keys
equal to
40
okay
ampersand ampersand
is sneak direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake direction
equal to
down so we are changing the directions
here
okay now let me try to copy this
and here we use elsif
[Music]
four times
okay so here we talk this
30 40 and here we say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 37
39 38 27
and here we say up
let's change to what
left
down
right
here we say
right
up
left
the three options we have changed and
last but not least here
i will just use
window dot
on key down
equal to
change directions
and
window
dot
on load
okay equal to
initialize that's how exactly we want to
use now and this function what we have
defined in initialize
okay so in this initialize
we are having this game start dot on
clicking and all so you have a call
start game now this start game will be
calling it here
okay so in start
we have a call snake we have called
snake dot push
and after that we are calling
this function call what
create food
clear interval and here we say
timer equal to
here set clear interval and here
change
game area
slash speed
size
let's say you want to use it
okay everyone so our code is almost
ready so we have this complete
javascript ready with me
now it's time to basically use within my
html
just to check how it may behave
so in my html page i have written this
normal speed
number
gamespeed value
button start we will call game start
after that we have a call canvas where
we can id equal to call game area
dev classic to relative
and
that's it and here we have a call script
sr is equal to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if i try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
i really do not see any changes in my
code
okay
despite i'm having this because
the css content is actually missing
okay because they're only my code really
look
better
because if there is no css
it wouldn't really make
good towards my application
okay and i also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
a little later on
let me go back and try to bring css into
this picture now
so first of all
have this
index.html file with me
and here i want to use css so inside my
head tag
we want to use
link
real
equal to
style sheet
okay href
equal to
app
dot
css
okay now
here
in my css we want to offer certain
details
what those details i want to start
working with i will start with my body
part
body
so we want to offer
the font family
so
font family maybe a little bit later on
i can use it first i want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
auto
letter text
align
center next font size
font size 150 pixels
also 150
and here we want to say background
background image
since i do not have any image so i will
just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise you have to say
url
and insert this url
give some values but i leave it as a
blank because i do not have any image i
will say background color
in this background color i can just use
white
after that height
i can just say 800 pixels
after that
background position
background position i want to use center
then background repeat
background repeat i want no repeat
then background size
okay let's see if there is a effect in
my
okay i see it's now
in the middle
better
now
inputs canvas we have to basically take
that here we just talk about call input
okay in this input i say font size
font size may be optional i can
make it
but let me just say font size 100
percent
then text align
center
then padding
i want to say five pixels
and
seven pixels
okay looks better now well here after
that i can use canvas
in this canvas
i want to see the background color
i just say white
after that border radius
order it is i can say 20 pixels
then
shadow if i want to use it
so i just say box shadow
box shadow i can say 3 pixels
5 pixels
and 6 pixels
and the color is
black
let's check
awesome
so i can see here
[Music]
the
logic is there so shadow you can easily
see how it has been using
and
that's it and this div
i can say
div
dot
relative
position
absolute
top
here i'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly
i program now when i say start
okay so there may be some error here
then they cannot set a property of call
on click
null
so this we can just check this into this
gamestop.onclick
let's check
anyways
we just try to fix that issue in a
while
but anyways we have our created css and
now going forward we'll be implementing
the rest of the logic within my code
okay everyone so we have changed some
names here because there was some value
was mismatched so we have basically
changed those values
with your properties and now when i try
to relaunch my application
by
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html file i try to
add
so
it's just as usual same let me say start
and here you can see game start when i
go up you see like it's starting right
now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play it earlier
okay but you can just change the
direction go up and you can see the
score 10 is being placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value call
what zero
by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
fine
so like that you can see and
automatically this will be position this
is what's called food that is how we
have used in my example on call app.js
you can see we are using this example
name called food
create food so in create food of the
specific interval time this would be
automatically created and the snake will
eat and increase the size of the code
okay that's it and now the css has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first game which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example now with that we have come to an
end of this tutorial on top projects for
2022. if you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in this
session or if you need the resources
that we have used in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you